car ban comment ça va
ça va bien didier
ça va très bien
tu veux tu veux rester là
c'est bien ses invités rapide c'est bien
n'a pas le temps de s'emmerder table
[Musique]
alors
t'as vu ce qui se passe à tous
[Musique]
à
non non non
venu sur le plateau de tout le monde en
parle l'émission du bal
avec nous ce soir christophe rauck au
pot
non
j'en veux plus
c'est un vrai lit car à
abu dhabi race trait d'huile
santos
alors mololo ça va c'est pas toi bah
écoute ça va pas de symptômes toujours
rien ça va naturellement siens sur un
peu enrhumé mais je suis bien sûr ce
soit la grippe aviaire là on vérifiera
bah ouais enfin les analyses c'est de
pire en pire les poils mais il reste 3
quand même s'ils ont pas mal à celle là
assez bien si orlando avec la run arbore
sur la tête ouais ouais ouais ouais
bon ça ça fait toujours plaisir bah
ouais
pas mal alors là on en prend bon on le
prend bien sûr qu'on en parle mais
non
le dernier missile code
aller mieux que moi mais bon que son
précédent
mais dépasse 50 cent cinquante n'ont pas
douté on va tout et a peur on va la
coupe et qu'elle s'est coupé la joconde
un pour nous si rien pour nous
que vous tous lendman
justement de sampler ouais non j'ai pas
de vanne cette semaine la sélection je
te préfère prévenir pas de 27 semaines
via des dossiers
[Applaudissements]
mais je vous emmerde
[Musique]
chacun christophe rocancourt
il s'offre aux concours ça va ça va ça
va alors christophe la presse vous a
baptisé l'escroc des stars de hollywood
mais on se rend compte en lisant votre
livre mais vit chez michel lafon que
c'est pas la meilleure définition et
surtout que c'est beaucoup mieux que ça
on pourrait dire vous êtes plutôt la
star les imposteurs nom wii
a fait un peu de mise
alors ce livre raconte quatre grandes
périodes de votre vie votre enfance en
normandie votre apprentissage de la vie
parisienne l'époque comme vous le dites
votre splendeur à paris puis à los
angeles et enfin la chute avant cinq ans
de prison au canada et aux états unis
[Applaudissements]
bientôt en france
fermée
alors dès votre sortie de prison vous
retournez sur les lieux de votre enfance
en normandie à pont-audemer tout
commence là un terrain derrière l'église
et le presbytère où le curé tolère la
caravane de vos parents vos parents
n'ont pas d'argent pour louer une maison
oui de mes parents sont beaux ma mère
est d'une beauté sensuelle
vénéneuse incandescent oui c'était une
belle femme ouais c'est ma mère votre
père costaud ouais courageux bagarreur
un peu ouais comme vous il le faut
alors vous dites mon père et ma mère
d'un amour idolâtre
mais ma mère n'aime pas mon père elle
même qu'elle même
oui
je pense qu'il ya des amours qui
ils sont pas ouais je pense que
ma mère était une belle femme
selon regret que tu savoir que j'ai vite
ça s'est vu à vis de mon père pour le
respect de mon père ouais c'est pas
passé comme ça ça marchait pas entre eux
quoi non je crois que mon père était un
petit peu les mets pas une femme l'aimé
des femmes mais je crois que ma mère ne
l'accepté pas ouais voilà donc mais
c'est toujours triste vis-à-vis d'un
enfant qui regarde sa mère et son père
on aime les deux est tous déçus donc
c'est difficile on peut comprendre mais
c'est difficile point pour un fils de
voir ce que mon père est devenu par
rapport à moi ma mère donc je le respect
de mon père alors ils sont rencontrés
vos parents dans une fête foraine il y
avait quelqu'un qui tentait de violer
votre mère votre père est arrivé tel
zorro il l'a sauvé
ils ont couché ensemble et vous naissez
vite c'est un accident bête
c'est un accident je sais pas si les
bêtes je crois que les choses se font
dans la vie il ya des gens qu'on est
destiné
sais pas si c'est de la bêtise mais bon
voilà c'est comme ça vous n'avez pas été
un enfant souhaité
je crois pas ouais c'est pas grave on
est là ouais alors votre père se bat
souvent dans les bars parce que ce sont
toujours les mêmes allusion qui le
rendent furieux car sa femme il faut le
dire votre mère se prostituent dans la
caravane je crois que ça énerve vrai
tout le monde ouais moi le premier ouais
voilà donc je pense que la colère de mon
père a été justifiée
voilà alors souvent votre mère vous
dites sortir dans la journée vous
traîner dans le village vous avez rien à
manger vous mettez à fouiller les
poubelles pouvoir bouffer
et vous avez cette phrase dans votre
bouquin qui est terrible vous dites il
ya toujours un imbécile de chiens pour
aboyer à la mort est une vieille pour
ricaner derrière ses rideaux ah oui je
pense qu'en fait les gens ils ont peu de
tolérance
ils ont un semblant de pitié en fait la
vie a fait que vaut apprendre
sinon vous donne rien points on comprend
que les jugera
quand même sujet sera alors un jour vous
vous cachez et vous regarder à travers
la fenêtre de la caravane et vous voyez
votre mère sous un homme elle est nue
lui l'ailé il est gras 8 elle a un
sourire halluciné et les jambes écartées
il vous dit que désormais vous serez
inapte à l'amour
je crois que lorsqu'on est jeune et
lorsqu'on est confronté à cette réalité
je crois que notre regard ils changent
c'est hier qu'on ne vient plus enfants
ouais j'ai depuis six ans la terre
ce qui met
une bousculade dans cette démarche
c'est comment une femme peut en arriver
à un tel désarroi cas puisse ne et puis
avoir le respect de son fils
l'a fait ses choix oui
et puis un jour votre mère s'en va alors
elle vous tourner carrément le dos elle
marche à pas pressés elle monte dans une
voiture vous vous courrez vous accrocher
à la la portière et elle vous dit dégage
elle vous claque la porte sur le doigt
et elle vous sectionne l'auriculaire
gauche
vous l'avez jamais revu
j'ai revu une fois ma mère un jeu les
revues pour simplement pour le regard
vient ensuite j'ai pris une décision
j'ai pris une décision ne jamais lui
reparler cette décision gelée basée sur
le fait pour l'amour et le respect que
j'avais mon père c'est un choix que j'ai
fait
un choix que j'assume et je
respecte ma mère par le fait qu'elle
m'ait donné la vie mais gésir pas que
une fois pas de quoi moi et ma mère on
peut parler en tant que
fils la mère soit parce qu'on pourrait
se dire
mais toujours en vie la wii elle vous
regardent peut-être
pas tête je n'ai rien à lui dire là
j'aime
voilà je la respecte ouais du fait que
c'est ma mère alors vous est envoyé chez
votre grand mère maternelle car la
nouvelle femme de votre père ne vous
veut pas et le compagnon de votre grand
mère maternelle c'est un gitan alors ça
comment ça se passait un peu mieux il
vous apprend à braconner et surtout il
vous apprend à rester de marbre quand
les gendarmes l'interrogé vous interroge
et plus tard ce sera utile avec les mecs
du fbi aie ça
c'est pas moi j'aime pas l'uniforme
ouais mais bon ça c'est moi ouais on
peut le comprendre
on vend père c'était quelqu'un de bien
quelqu'un que j'aimais beaucoup
il parlait le romano on se comprenait
pas ouais mais
tu t'es un mec bien avec livre plus
beaucoup de gens livre
voilages et puis quand on est jeune
grand-voile or il semble my way c'est
bien tu es bien des gipsy ouais enfin et
tout ce qui à ce jour n'est besoin de
chaussures ils vont chaparder une paire
enfin je veux dire c'est voilà bah oui à
nîmes avait viré de l'école ouais
j'avais pas de chaussures dont furent
envoyés
on a fait du chemin depuis justement
c'est là vous apprenez à raconter des
histoires vous démarrez votre carrière
de bonimenteur vous dites comme votre
grand-père et romano vous dites que
c'est un chef indien et vous vous êtes
pieds nus parce que vous êtes indiens
aussi que vous faites ça commence très
jeune votre idée oui je pense que
lorsqu'on a une enfance quand même comme
la nôtre je suis pas le seul y en a
beaucoup je pense qu'en fait on veut
fuir vous savez les enfants jouer j'ai
un fils qu'est-ce qu'ils font sont tous
devant imaginer ouais ils jouent avec
leurs jouets il rêve
puis
lorsque à cette réalité en fait on
essaie d'en échapper
c'est assez intéressant de savoir
comment de notre mémoire peut être
sélectif dans mon cas
j'aimais bien rêver ouais y avait pas
grand chose à rêver à la maison donc on
en rêvait ailleurs
le doyen dire à cette époque là
sympa d'être à nay très sympa et alors
c'est surtout une époque où vous
découvrez la lecture et nietzsche et
vous en parler plus loin dans le livre
la mort faty c'est à dire l'amour du
destin c'est à dire aimer ce qui vous
arrive que ce soit bien ou mal j'ai
toujours aimé beaucoup nietzsche pas ce
que c'était c'était quelqu'un qui était
pas conclut intellectuellement il ya
beaucoup de corrompus intellectuelle
nietzsche il avait une vraie vérité une
vraie démarche il était tête compris les
petits étaient torturés je pense que sa
démarche il était vrai
et ce qui est vrai par l'existence et
par la preuve des choses tout ce qui tue
pas vous rend plus fort ouais voilà on
regarde un va-nu-pieds puis bah
hollywood je crois que c'est la
détermination qui fait les choses à 10
ans votre père vous emmène dans un
orphelinat et là vous devenez vraiment
le fils de personne quoi parce que vous
n'avez plus plus de famille des cuivres
et complètement à vous même c'est très
difficile à ce moment là ouais c'est
difficile
c'est quelque chose
je crois que il ya beaucoup de gens qui
passent par des difficultés dans
l'existence
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup de mal à
comprendre
par rapport aux enfants est quelque
chose qui me dérange énormément du ce
soit les parents qui abandonnent leurs
enfants qui font cette démarche
est quelque chose de très très malsain
dans cette démarche puisque c'est ta
chère ouais c'est ce que tu fais ce que
tu es c'est une partie de toi même
je n'arrive pas à comprendre on peut
trouver sans doute des circonstances
atténuantes vis-à-vis il a vite ça mais
c'est pas un justificatif alors à 15 ans
vous débarquez à paris vous est
recueillie par un homme d'une vingtaine
d'années qui s'appelle gilles qui vous
trouvent sur un banc dans une station de
métro c'est miraculeux est un gosse de
riche qui s'ennuient qui est branché jet
set qui vous emmène partout mais pas de
relation homosexuelle
fait pas répondre à ça moi ça m'arrive
de voir des gens qui sont pauvres ils
sont dans la rue ce m'arrête et je parle
avec eux vous savez je crois qu'on en
est on à ya quelque chose qui se passe
dans l'une ans aujourd'hui c'est
personnes s'arrêtent on pense qu'on est
tous quelque chose d'exceptionnel
quelque chose d'absolument
on est juste de passage la réalité elle
est là
les gens veulent pas la voir et la
réalité elle est là on est tous que ce
soit les gens qui vous voit publiquement
on reste que des humains on est fragile
on et voilà donc il faut s'arrêter
pourquoi il s'est arrêté sa démarche où
ils sont emmerdés où il avait peut-être
pitié je ne sais pas mais j'ai eu
l'occasion de le remercier parce qu'il
le regarde je remercie voix la voix et
les braves nec ouais dans tous les cas
nous on est vraiment partout vous avez
connu le palace est connu les grands
restaurants parisiens enfin la bonne vie
et à 19 ans qui s'offrent au concours
vous commencez vos premières combine
alors pardon vous fait passer pour un
élève de l'ena un palais nan nan mais
vous fait passer pour un élève de l'ena
qui veut lancer un club chic dans le
marais alors il ya un mec qui vous
prêtent 500 mille francs aux blacks
en liquide ah oui évidemment un échec
chez nous évidemment la faire se fait
pas et comme le mec c'était de l'argent
en salle il vous le réclame pas bah
voilà donc vous gardez des cinq cent
mille balles voila voila commence fort
je sais pas si c'était fort on commence
et ce qui est génial c'est que vous
arrivez comme ça vous faire passer pour
un élève de l'ena le mec s'aperçoit de
rien
je sais pas peut-être les énarques sont
endormis ouais peut-être leurs neurones
fonctionne pas bien
alors il ya quand même quelque chose qui
revient sans arrêt dans votre livre
c'est que vous jouez sur la cupidité des
gens dire que les gens vous escroquer
c'est toujours des gens qui sont âpres
au gain quelqu'un qui est foncièrement
honnête pape allait prendre le large
voilà ça c'est la première chose et la
deuxième chose aussi qui revient dans
votre bouquin c'est le train de vie
important c'est à dire que toujours vous
arriver très bien ça paie quand c'est
los angeles avec des hélicoptères des
blondes ton palais blanc que c'est bien
non oui si on n'est pas [__] c'est très
bien
toujours un train de vie important à
christophe on aime vivre confortablement
à un moment c'est juste après vous
devenez christophe d'euros concours
sympathique d'ailleurs on membres et du
courrier on n'en dort verger remercie
mon minute christophe leur concours pour
falsifier des titres de propriété
appartenant aux parents de votre petite
amie oui j'ai vendu l'immeuble
là vous retrouver en taule quand même et
vous rencontrer l'assassin d'alain
pacadis je rencontrais une personne qui
voit là
étaient impliqués dans cette histoire je
sais pas ce qui s'est passé dans la
suite dont qui a aidé alain pacadis à
mourir on peut le dire il faut donner il
faut donner le bénéfice du doute dans
son histoire je la connais pas franchir
mais voilà mais vous l'aviez connu alain
pacadis julien libération il serait
intelligent oui traces de la nuit
c'était un dandy way après ce séjour en
prison vous parti aux usa à los angeles
alors là adresse de prestige voitures
haut de gamme vous devenez un pee pôle
incontournable
c'est extraordinaire comment un type
comme vous qui sort de pont-audemer
comment vous arrivez à devenir un pipeau
la contournable à los angeles
je pense que il ya des choses qui sont
incontournables
lorsqu'on a une certaine aisance
financière lorsqu'on arrive avec des
volumes fort
tous ceux se remet ensemble que ce soit
à tort showbiz
c'est la même cuisine donc voilà
l'argent appelle l'argent vous fait
passer pour le fils du producteur dino
de laurentiis sympa et ça marche haas a
marché
on a vous devenez ami avec jean claude
van damme mickey rourke que michel
polnareff vous dites j'irais jamais pris
un sou d'abord en parlant de l'art et
vous dites pour se faire subtiliser 250
mille dollars il faut les avoir
café et puis vous dites ils ont jamais
porté plainte en fait
alors là vous rencontrer la fille du
président omar bongo et vous obtenez un
passeport américain vous dites c'est le
summum de mes rêves le passeport
américain pourquoi oui c'était
sympathique partant de normandie avec
les petites étoiles l'amérique pas mal
alors vous continuez vos arnaque mais
l'étau se resserre encore un coup fumant
sous le nom de christophe rockefeller
c'est extraordinaire c'est que personne
mais c'est incroyable là on voit deux
corées un chat c'est fou ça en dit long
quand même sur la bêtise humaine cher
que personne ne réalise et met le
descendant de rockefeller à un anglais
approximatif les jeux c'est à dire que
c'est même plus de la bêtise ouais ils
ont un problème de neurones ouais
c'est plus de la bêtise c'est fou la
bêtise on peut se tromper ouais là c'est
de la connerie humaine
sait déjà que vous êtes christophe
rockefeller oui non non mais bon
c'est pathétique ouais
ouais ce qu'on peut dire de plus c'est
pathétique
ce qui est encore plus pathétique c'est
qu'ils font des affaires ouais de
mauvaises un témoin rencontre
alors vous vous retrouvez en prison
d'abord au canada puis aux usa et vous
raconter dans ce livre donc mais vie
vous raconter la prison américaine le
choc par exemple le chemin c'est une
arme d'une arme bricoler avec n'importe
quoi en fait c est l arme blanche quoi
vous pouvez vous pourrez prendre un
stylo
voilà vous pouvez prendre
une boîte de thon vous une boîte de thon
le serbe ouvriers ont les dix voulez
vous mettez du rivage à la machine à
cirage la matinée je retourne voilà elle
retournera faire
et va vous parler de la haine raciale et
de la guerre des gangs dans ces prisons
américaines vous dites qu'on peut tuer
pour un oui pour un non par exemple un
jour il ya un mec qui touche à un
plateau-repas de quelqu'un d'autre six
morts le système carcéral américain et
beaucoup différent
de notre système en europe 1,6 entre
violon
le milieu carcéral en france c'est le
milieu carcéral américain cessé ces deux
mondes lointains
c'est incomparable aux états unis la vie
n'a pas vraiment beaucoup de prix
c'est effarant par exemple à new york
je crois que c'était en 2002 2003 il y
avait des jeunes qui venaient pour les
baskets des nike il y avait toute une
mode de nike était sortie et il y avait
des jeunes qui mettait des cagoules et
passait dans la rue par la 5e avenue
et prenez basket
j'ai pas c'est quand même effarant
non il avant de flinguer le mec
peut-être pour mieux lui demander sa
pointure au moins quelqu'un
serait préférable mais si vous avez le
temps c'est ça le problème même avoir le
temps
alors le producteur thomas langmann
qu'ils paradent votre fils est venu vous
voir en prison au canada oui il va faire
un film à partir de votre vie tout à
fait vous avez joué le rôle
non je pense pas pourquoi non je crois
qu'il faut laisser ça aux
personnes qui sont qui sont doués pour
faire
alors maintenant vous étrangers rangée
où ils tranquille vous avez payez votre
dette à la société je donnais 1,2
million de dollars à la justice
américaine c'est un bon citoyen
maintenant un bon citoyen france calle
vos impôts 33% ben voila vous ai des
regrets il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
disent ah oui ce regret ouais la
démarche n'est pas là pour moi je pense
que lorsqu'on la société vous condamnent
vous avez commis un délit
vous payer 50 votre existence 4 mètres
sur 4 m qu'est ce que vous voulez je
vous dise de plus ouais donc il faut que
je fasse 50 prison que je paye ma dette
et qu'est ce que vous voulez à pourvoir
qu'est ce que voulez vous que je vous
dise excusez moi je peux plus m'excuser
j'ai payé 5 ans je ne dois rien donc
coin vous dites on est tous ces
imposteurs parce qu'on essaie tous des
chapelles réalité d'une manière ou d'une
autre bien sûr
la réalité elle n'est pas très belle non
moi je passais tout à l'heure et je
regardais sur un trottoir je voyais
quelqu'un qui avait une tente sur trois
toits ouais
on va mal ouais on va vraiment mal
s'arrêtent même pu on regarde on dira
oui c'est triste on a un petit regard de
compassion mais en fait la bière
continue donc ses il ya quand même
quelque chose de vraiment très malsain
dans cette démarche alors vous en faites
vous avez voulu échapper à votre vie on
l'a vu la vie avec cette mère qui se
prostituent dans la caravane c'est pour
cela sans doute que vous avez essayé de
vivre toutes ces autres existence
maintenant que vous l'avez raconté dans
ce livre blanc vous avez avoué est-ce
que avoué c'est fini quoi maintenant
vous savez de ce à quoi c'est pas le
fait d'être libéré et je crois qu'il ya
un moment de son existence on fait ce
qu'on doit faire puis ensuite on tourne
la page et si on tourne une page en quoi
qu'on fait on la tourne dans les
vêtements il faut
passer à autre chose vous êtes
réconcilier que vos fantôme maintenant
je leur parle
lorsque vous avez été arrêté à vancouver
vous aviez 4 bible dans un sac louis
vuitton vous dit la foi a toujours
dominé ma vie bien sûr quand vous étiez
en prison vous priez beaucoup et je
pense pas que c'est le fait d'être en
prison je pense qu'on il faut rester
humble je pense que
penser qu'on ait lieu
la supériorité dans l'humanité c'est de
la vanité à mon sens il est bien évident
qu'il ya quelque chose de supérieur donc
on l'appelle dieu voilà il a et ya eu
beaucoup de compassion à mon égard je
l'en remercie on reverra nos comptes
plus tard
question trop grand tour mais minutes
c'est publié chez michel lafon mesdames
messieurs
christophe formateur une interview
attrape moi si tu peux
quelle a été l'hymne entités que vous
avez préféré prendre à calais
quelle identité avez-vous gardé le plus
longtemps 3 populaire
qu'est l'identité était la plus
difficile à porter 3faire quelle
identité était vraiment une mauvaise
idée
rockefeller
quelle identité vous ressembler le plus
que tu vas être surpris
or en cours
quel est votre plus beau coup
celui à
qu'est-ce qui vous n'avez plus rapporté
les affaires qu'est ce qui vous avait
plus amusé
la connerie humaine
qu'est-ce qui a été le plus dur
cinq ans de prison
à quel moment vous êtes dit je vais trop
loin
quand l'avez vu à aimar est
qu'est-ce qui vous motive et le plus
parti de rien d'arriver
qu'est ce qui a failli vous griller le
plus souvent
moi même
à quoi était vous particulièrement bon
connaître la nature humaine
qui avez vous toujours refusé d'arnaquer
les personnes qui ont rien
à qui n'avez vous jamais pu piquer de la
thune
ce qu avait pas de vanité
combien avez vous mis de côté un peu
combien
1 et des 0 combien avez vous dû rendre
un million de dollars ah oui mais billet
vert quelle fut votre plus grosse erreur
prendre l'argent
je c'est vrai j'ai et avancés toray un
million de 2 valent un bon on va
repartir on va aller les voir alors
demandé qu'il nous fasse un reçu qu'est
ce qui vous a trahis l'amitié
ça vous combien les droits de votre
histoire pour le cinéma
un million d'euros
vous voyez qui pour jouer votre rôle au
cinéma samy naceri
beaune akers ça c'est pas bête très
bonne à que je pense qu'il a
il a des convictions faut lui laisser
vincent cassel je le rencontre et ouais
j'ai pas regardé c'est du club américain
johnny depp non c'est un mec bien
et maintenant c'est fini les conneries
j'arrête les conneries si ça a été des
conneries ça passe je pense pas que ça a
été des conneries c'était une démarche
elle est était pas bonne mais je vois
pas de calais dans ça
michel à pont-l'abbé cieux
accueil diane kruger et fabienne
berthaud
bonsoir les filles d'alain
les couples se forment il manque plus qu
un ouais faut pas le poser comment ça va
très bien vous alors jen vous avez
déclaré je suis pas très à l'aise sur un
plateau de télé car le français n'est
pas ma langue maternelle et j'ai peur de
ne pas trouver les mots justes si on
m'attaque est vrai qu emma j'espère bien
pourquoi voudriez vous qu'on vous
attaque de charmantes pas j'espère même
un traducteur
voilà c'est à cause des gens comme ça
en fait j'ai du mal à vous sentir à
l'aise qu'à vous avez peur de pas être à
la hauteur des attentes placées en vous
j'ai des attentes très haute ma propre
carrière pour ma propre vie donc
forcément j'ai envie d'être à la hauteur
là quand on voit votre filmographie vous
êtes très à la hauteur on va pas citer
tous les films enfin celui dans mon
idole de guillaume canet vous étiez très
bien dans 3 le groupe est plein
bollywoodien vous étiez bien aussi très
éclectique
joyeux noël parfaite nommé aux oscars
bientôt les brigades du tigre est
aujourd'hui francky de fabienne berthaud
bonsoir on se marre alors c'est
l'histoire d'une dune mannequine de 26
ans plus assez jeune et plus assez belle
et qui flippe complètement et qui se
retrouvent dans un hôpital psychiatrique
car vous l'avez rencontré quand elle
avait 16 ans diab c'est marrant parce
que je les jeux les rencontrer au début
de sa carrière de mannequin chez lutte
chez élite et je les ai retrouvés chez
pas huit ans après pour lui faire passer
des essais pour francky mais voilà elle
est en fin de carrière
j'ai rappelle gerald j'ai raté sa
carrière en fait en fait à l'époque vous
étiez un peu dans le rôle parce que vous
étiez
man king qui voulaient pu faire ce
boulot quoi c'est un peu l'histoire du
film d'une certaine façon pas exactement
c'est une des raisons pour laquelle je
trouvais vraiment intéressante une des
raisons pourquoi moi j'ai arrêté ce
métier c'est vraiment on connaît tous le
métier de la mode est forcément des
mannequins sont vus pour leur plastique
pour leurs extérieurs et moi en ville
sans forcément j'avais envie d'y à
manger voilà j'ai grandi quoi et c'était
insupportable de regarder des gens sur
moi que sur sa sont censés souci c'est
moi je vais bien ou pas et donc ce film
là qui n'est pas encore une fois c'est
pas une procès de la mode francky mais
qui parle justement d'une jeune fille
fragile qui n'arrivent plus à vivre dans
notre société moi j'ai vraiment connu ça
encore aujourd'hui je ressens vachement
un sens de déracinement j'habite en
france aujourd'hui mais je suis pas
française en allemagne je me sens
vraiment étrangères mais je peux
américaine je me sens des fois vraiment
encore très perdu alors ce qui est
terrible c'est que le producteur voulait
quelqu'un de plus connu que diane qui
vous a laissé tomber dont vous avez été
obligé de produire le film français -
oui aussi séparés - cc
je cherchais vraiment un mannequin qui
avait le potentiel d'une actrice et une
actrice qui joue un mannequin c'est
difficile de a dit croire en tout cas à
mon sens est donc effectivement on s'est
séparés et on a déjà je me suis acheté
une caméra numérique et et puis voilà on
a décidé de faire le film comme ça le
problème c'est comme parallèlement les
devenu star le tournage s'est étalé sur
trois ans voilà c'était un problème mais
maintenant c'est se donner un avantage
alors vous comment c'était c'était
terrible parce que il ya des moments où
j'étais en train de tourner dans le
monde entier vous étiez obligés de
continuer le film avec fabienne ya des
moments où vous avez envie de laisser
tomber quand même beaucoup ouais j'étais
pas obligé d continué m a laissé le
choix mais d'abord fabien était la
première me faire confiance c'est
vraiment je n'oublierai jamais ça parce
que elle a laissé voilà elle a pu faire
son film en tout confort avec quelqu'un
de plus connus donc déjà ça et surtout
c'était un rôle pour une actrice en
général que caen n'a pas au début de
carrière et je pense aujourd'hui c'est
certainement le rôle le plus abouti que
moi j'ai fui en tant que je l' ai vu le
film c'est pas mal c'est un film
disloqué un peu comme le comme le
personnage que vous incarnez à mi chemin
entre le documentaire et la fiction
puisque giral marie le patron de
l'agencé élite joue son propre rôle
christian vigueur le photographe de mode
aussi
dans l'hôpital psychiatrique où elle va
ces sont les vrais malades qui est qui
qui joue donc c'est très très étonnant
c'est très intéressant ces films et en
dv avec une lumière naturelle donc ça
donne des images on pense un peu au film
indépendant des années soixante dix
films américains comme ça va mal
c'est vrai ça ressemble un peu à un
portrait d'une enfant déchue de jerry
schatzberg ya beaucoup c'est un peu le
même esprit quoi sauf que la fille et
moi jusqu'au boutiste peut-être elle se
drogue pas lui aiderait dans le film
chaque plaque on va vraiment 110 lits à
on s'était mis en scène est ici c'est
plus beaucoup dans ce lot voilà on va
regarder à quoi ça ressemble et regardez
votre caméra toutes les deux c'est le
cas de rouge vous allez dire magnéto
serge
allemagne et sincère non à ta bière
dakar 1 2 3 maniez de lozère giat
[Musique]
qu'elle a maintenant elle pas avoir agi
par m6 un sommet à 27 points
en tout cas ouais mais tu me l'envoie et
on va voir
je trouve
[Musique]
chaque fois qu'il fallait qu'un connard
tu vas rester chez toi sa folle semaine
avec la pêche tels que c'est un gros
tous les gros trucs en ce moment ça
court pas les
métiers avec que habituellement qu'est
ce qui a bien pu se passer vous
[Applaudissements]
c'est toi la visite pendant ce temps là
les vaches mondiale cette logique oui
c'est deux soeurs qui s'appelle les
cocorosie ah ouais c'est très très rare
et donc pendant tout le film comme ça
c'est vrai ouais elles ont sorti un
album qui s'appelle la maison de mon
rêve et qu'elles ont autoproduit aussi
lesquels ont fait dans leur salle de
bain avec des jouets d'enfants et des
trucs comme ça non c'est vraiment génial
alors quand vous étiez mannequin vous
avez été humiliée comme ça comme on voit
dans le film une scène terrible où elle
l'entend le photographe ses assistants
qui parle d'elle en lisons mais les
vieilles à limoges il n'y arrivera pas
ça vous est arrivé des moments marquants
safram l'armée ça m'est arrivé bien
surtout il ya plus la scène du shooting
où est le photographe est vraiment
médiocre et c'est parce qu'il fait ce
jour-là foutu mannequin s'est même
jamais sa faute à lui ça j'ai vraiment
dû cul ouais mais bon il ya des deux
côtés encore une fois dans ce métier-là
jeu j'ai aussi les faits d expérience
très positive si je vis aujourd'hui en
france je parle français c'est grâce à
ça donc il y aller du côté je pense que
francky c'est bon c'est l'histoire de
quelqu'un qui n'arrive plus à vivre avec
cet aveu avec avec ce regard soit elle
cette société qui tous à la beauté la
jeunesse etc ou bien une vie de merde
parce que non mais c'est vrai la vie
dans cette vie là qu'est la vraie vie
l'a d'ailleurs dit je vais à disney ses
mannequins et on voit la taille des
chambres va l'ambiance entre les filles
qui sont là qui s'ennuient qui fument
des clopes toute la journée enfin si
c'est un film à montrer à toutes les
jeunes filles qui va être mannequin à
cette terrible
donc c'est pour ça vous avez voulu
devenir actrice qua non non pas du tout
non c'était un rêve depuis très
longtemps mais encore une fois c'est
tellement un cliché les mannequins qui
veut qu'il veut devenir actrice
pendant très longtemps au contraire j'ai
hésité de prendre des cours et en fait
j'ai vraiment fait le pas parce que j'ai
j'ai vécu une histoire d'amour qui s'est
très mal passée aux états unis dès lors
à new york voilà qui m'a vraiment brisé
le coeur et pendant très longtemps
j'étais très malheureuse et puis je suis
rentré en france j'ai quitté tout d'un
jour à l'autre et ça te fait quoi de le
revoir ça
ça remue des choses
vous êtes retrouver célibataire pendant
un an à votre retour à paris et ça vous
allez rencontrer guillaume canet et
c'est guillaume canet qui vous a fait
prendre des cours chez florent mais
encouragé moi c'est bien du bois tu me
va beaucoup ouais c'est difficile de
concilier mariage et carrière quand même
c'est possible mais ça peut être aussi
difficile parce que là vous partez sans
arrêt vous oui je suis beaucoup par ses
partisans aux états unis pour faire 3
pieds au mexique 4
je n'avais pas encore entendu serviront
à 2 27 semaines
c'est leclerc
way pourtant la dernière fois qu'on
s'était vue là la promo de joyeux noël
et tout faisait-il ça se passait plutôt
bien ça a été subie quand même cette
histoire avec guillaume cette rupture
c'est la ville est partie en vacances
ensemble peut-être jamais là en vacances
non moi je me disais si on est parti en
vacances mais c'est la vie voilà ça
s'explique mouais
voilà vous êtes célibataire voilà
vous retournez voir vos parents
d'allemagne des fois oui oui c'est bien
sûr mais je suis très proche avec mes
grands-parents donc casser
encore dans le petit village où je suis
né à garrison ça vous manque l'allemagne
non non pas vraiment climat quand même
un peu visible en hiver une interview
achtung
est-ce que vous allez à la fête de la
bière tous les ans je ne suis jamais
allé là près d'y aller voilà un truc mon
nom je vais aller voilà un truc
conférence vous faites des couettes
régulièrement oui ah oui ça
régulièrement mais samara d'études
tresques voilà vous aimez l'ordre délier
au carré ça dépend dans quoi dans
certaines choses lui dans certains
sports d'élite chez toi
ça va chez elle c'est pas du tout ranger
au travail plutôt en ce moment oui j'en
italienne ouais j'ai de ponctuelles oui
à défaut des fois je dois faire le tour
du quartier parce que je suis dix
minutes en avance vous êtes vraiment
blonde un peu chien battu
[Rires]
vous manger des saucisses tous les jours
non je rigole bien j'aime ça
vous consommez beaucoup sur autoroute
ouais vous écoutait du wagner pour vous
endormir puisses-tu beethoven j'ai fait
un film d'ailleurs son avis de beethoven
et j'adore j'adore est ce que vous
croyez un petit peu supérieur aux autres
mois non au contraire au contraire
vous mettez des chaussures avec des
semelles de bois l'été
ça m'arrive aussi oui
est-ce que à l'âge de 40 ans vous allez
prendre 30 kg
alors j'ai bien peur c'est possible car
ma mère et ma grand-mère sans un peu
forte voilà vous dépêcher à la carte au
fun ça
[Applaudissements]
sort le 1er mars pour arriver
[Musique]
or
à
de toi coeur
az voiture avec d'après j'ai pas encore
vu ce
alors qu'à ça fait du bien vous de dire
du mal de guillaume que c'est impossible
un truc un petit truc impossible un
petit truc médiatique ya bien un truc
négatif guillaume
il est très bordélique ah ça me rendait
dingue ah ben voilà pas du tout
bordélique c'est vrai et la truite la
truite fléchoise 4,8 pour bram 1 voilà
au moment
in time biche la halde h classe il faut
a dit là où nichent forêt le faut
quant à jane lynch tendre hunza yousri
dont c'est un joli choc aurait
l'euphorie barbie amf ait dit
l'artichaut forêt l'euphorie barbie en
faillite sur 10
c'est vraiment pour toi c'est vrai je
suis parti sur dish mind chatte
match at il n est pas moi je parlais de
mon refus si ça veut dire quoi ça va
m'aider montrésor bon christophe g vous
libérez libérez christophe tubéry
hier
j'accueille luc ferry
[Musique]
messieurs ça va
regarder ça peut être pire oui ça
commence pas mal ça commence sympa oui
vous regrettez pas pu être ministre
l'éducation nationale non bon et honnête
non non mais cela dit je regrette pas
d'avoir été non plus à dégraisser le
mammouth un peu avant de partir je
craque la bête soit restée en l'état
personne n'est parfait
puis en plus vous avez vu ce qu'ils vous
ont succédé il en paye plus de chance
que vaut un oui c'est vrai que je
m'aperçois que j'ai eu une longévité
assez assez remarquable puisque
finalement les autres ont giclé aussi à
cette arène fillon qu'est ce qui met un
nom un an et c'est que j'ai maintenant
chez lui qui sait maintenant c'est qu'il
l'a ils sont méchants quand même a
alors été arrêté catherine barma me dit
dans l'oreillette gilles de robien ah
oui je le comprends et perben mois ils
se ressemblent un peu à des cadavres ou
c'est bizarre avec
madame henri lacroix saint mich exact
vous savez ça
nous l'avons réussi son 3e st donc
ils sont pas alignés les trois comme ça
non y'en as tu sais pas si c'est pas les
deux reprises le club de billard il a
deux soeurs et un qui est là oui c'est
vrai il nous l'a montré
d'une image dans la tête là
pour équilibrer d'accueil
vraiment
voilà la todo
célibataire vous n'êtes pas célibataire
mon chien noël et la
caroline absolument là vous surveille
non non mais enfin n'est pas loin quand
même
vite et la mairie caroline vient
âge la loi
rozier
v
maman est dans le coin elle est à la
maison et elle garde les enfants voilà
la paire élevé à une femme aussi je lis
on l'invite choix de la tête et des
jambes ça va très bien très bien et
alors dites-moi commencé depuis qu'il
n'est plus ministre vous avez tout à
vous alors c'est bien oui je l'avais
déjà tout un mois ouais ouais et alors
partager un peu il n'a pas souffert de
sa non pas du tout non bien ouais et
vous êtes tous maintenant aux castes
c'est quoi le casse c'est une chose qui
s'appelle le conseil d' analyse la
société sts à matignon auprès du premier
ministre et ce assez c'est en fait très
sympathique parce que j'ai la chance
d'être entouré d'une trentaine de
personnes
personnalités de la société civile
savate david douillet à danièle thompson
en passant par des historiens des
chercheurs des biologistes des médecins
et on travaille sur les questions de
société par exemple le prochain rapport
qu'ont publicité sur les cellules
souches je peux changer vos places là
bien de vous mettez là parce que je oui
parce que toi
c'est quoi marie caroline êtes très bien
avec moi et des questions sexuelles
après
la merci fabienne voilà tous les deux au
regard des champions garder comme ils
sont beaux là
[Applaudissements]
ça
bien alors vous publié chez plon un
livre qui s'appelle apprendre à vivre
est un petit traité de philosophie à
usage des jeunes générations
alors ma fille tu vas suivre là parce
que normalement tu dois arriver à suivre
il a fait pour sa fille elle a quel âge
elle avait 12 ans à l'époque donc je
vais pouvoir vérifier d'accord je trouve
accroché alors qu'est ce que la
philosophie on a combien de temps une
heure non mais moi je vais te le dire la
philosophie c'est l'autre réponse à
l'angoissé des hommes
la première étant la religion évidemment
et c'est un salut sans dieu la
philosophie voilà c'est ce que vous
dites dans votre livre c'est assez
lumineuse c'est assez simple comme
définition alors ça paraît idiot mais
j'ai mis trente ans à comprendre
vraiment ça et et l'idée que je
développe dans ce livre et qui me permet
de raconter à des gens qui n'ont jamais
fait philosophie vraiment l'histoire de
la philosophie en rentrant quand même à
fond dans les grands grande vision du
monde c'est l'idée que on part
évidemment tous d'un certain nombre de
peurs on a des valeurs qui sont ça peut
être les peurs qu'on a devant un
personnage célèbre quand on vient d'un
milieu modeste ça peut être les peurs
qu'on a quand on a des phobies par
exemple ça est-ce que c'est qu'elle
établit des toques n'importe et puis il
ya une grande peur qui nous malgré tout
qui nous anime tous c'est évidemment la
peur de la mort pas simplement la sienne
mais surtout souvent la peur de la mort
des autres des gens qu'on aime et cette
question là on n'en parle pas beaucoup
la cache souvent mais les grandes
religions ils y ont répondu elles sont
des civils et des doctrines du salut
avec dieu elles vous disent au fond mais
tu n'auras plus peur si tu te mets dans
la main de dieu et que tu te laisse
porter par la croyance et la croyance ça
veut dire aussi la confiance et les
grandes philosophies moi je vous dis une
chose ça n'est rien d'autre qu'une
tentative de répondre exactement la même
question sur comment se débarrasser de
la peur et notamment de la peur de la
mort avec l'idée qu'on ne peut bien
vivre que si on se débarrasse des peurs
mais essayer d'y répondre sans faire
appel à dieu voile attendant dit non pas
par la foi mais par la raison alors lu
que vous racontez les cinq grands
moments de l'histoire de la philosophie
et c'est assez intéressante parce que on
voit bien l'évolution humaine tiers vous
commencez avec la philosophie antique
alors la naissance de la philosophie en
fait sénat en grèce au vième siècle
avant jésus-christ qu'on appelle le
miracle grec et jusque là les religions
détenait le monopole et là c'est la
première recherche rationnelle donc vous
dit sans doute parce que la cité avait
une nature démocratique c'est ça oui
parce que la démocratie est là elle a
engendré chez les chez les humains aux
graisses cette volonté d'argumenter de
démontrer d'essayer de d'échanger des
opinions et par conséquent la
philosophie est certainement né en
relation avec cet univers dans lequel on
avait pris l'habitude de débattre de
discuter encore une fois d'argumenter
est donc d'essayer de comprendre le
monde et de répondre à cette grande
question du salut par la raison plutôt
que par la foi et la première grande
réponse
philosophique à la question de la peur
de la mort et comment s'en débarrasser
c'est la réponse des grandes visions du
monde qui sont développés à partir de
peut-être le premier grand philosophe
parménide qui est qui et qui est le
philosophe qui va dominer la pensée
avant platon jusqu'à jusqu'au grand
stoichkov jusqu'à françois valéry qui
disait et non aimons nous vivent dehors
il ya un truc moi qui m'a surpris c'est
que la philosophie antique donc grecque
est assez proche du bouddhisme
finalement parce que l'essence du monde
c'est l'harmonie c'est le cosmos mais
les grands mots si la nostalgie
l'espérance il faut vivre l'instant
c'est très bouddhiste non attachement
aux possessions ou bien de ce monde
seulement est ce qu'est ce que la
philosophie grecque a inspiré le
bouddhisme vous croyez pas ce que c'est
la même chose non je pense qu'ils se
retrouvent sur des grands thèmes et vous
avez tout à fait raison de dire s'il ya
une très grande proximité entre la
philosophie stoïcienne en particulier et
puis là le bouddhisme vous explique ça
en deux mots les grecs en particulier
stoïcienne ils vont ils imaginaient que
le monde ce qu'ils appelaient le cosmos
en grec ça veut dire un ordre simplement
était comme un organisme vivant que tu
sais quand un physiologiste ou un
médecin ouvre un organisme vivant il
voit que tout est merveilleusement bien
fait que les choses sont à leur place
quand vous regardez un oeil c'est
incroyablement bien fichu les poumons
tout est merveilleusement bien fait et
les grecs s'imaginait que l'ensemble du
monde était cet ordre qui était s'était
offert un gros êtres vivants si vous
voulez et le but de la philosophie
c'était deux choses c'est tout simple 1
comprendre cet ordre le contempler
essayer de comprendre comment il marche
et 2 trouver sa place sa juste place à
l'intérieur de cet univers
merveilleusement ordonné magnifiquement
fait et quand on avait trouvé sa place
dans le monde comme le cosmos pour les
grecs le monde était éternelle eh bien
on s'apercevait d'une chose très
importante c'est que la mort n'était
qu'un passage et qu'au fond c'était une
transformation d'un état à un autre et
ça permettait justement un peu comme
dans le bouddhisme de vaincre cette peur
primaire qui est la peur de la mort et
donc le but de la philosophie c'était un
de comprendre le monde deux dossiers
ajusté c'était tout l'art à l'e3
pourquoi et bien justement pour vaincre
la peur de la mort pourquoi le
christianisme a t'il vaincu cette
philosophie grecque parce qu'il n'était
pas un rist aux pratiques et on se rend
compte que le christianisme en fait
c'est l'invention de la démocratie
c'est-à-dire l'égalitarisme dire tous
les êtres humains sont égaux alors les
grecs avaient en effet l'idée que le
monde était hiérarchiser qui avait nié
archi naturel des êtres il était dans un
monde aristocratique ce que la morale
chrétienne va inventer qui est génial
qu'on voit dans la parabole des talents
dans l'évangile en particulier c'est
l'idée que comment dire la dignité des
êtres humains ne dépend pas des talents
naturels du fait qu'on soit excellent
parce qu'on peut très fort on peut très
beau on peut être très intelligent tout
ce que vous voulez comme talent naturel
mais on peut en faire le pire usages
qu'ils soient l'idée c'est que
[Rires]
c'est que en gros la dignité d'un être
humain ne dépend pas de ses talents
naturels au départ ça c'est la vision
aristocratique du monde mais la dignité
d'un être humain dépend de ce qu'il en
fait de ce point de vue là on est tous à
égalité quelle que soit la base de
départ ce qui compte c'est ce qu'on va
en faire et là d'une certaine façon en
effet les chrétiens à vente la première
morale démocratique c'est la première
mort à nous nous sommes tous à égalité à
la soeur du monde aristocratique
l'esprit est plus importante que la
lettre c'est à dire que jésus défend la
femme adultère et malgré la loi et ça
c'est génial parce que moi je suis pas
chrétien mais franchement si j'avais un
livre à emporter sur l'île déserte
j'emporterai l'évangile de jean et en
particulier je trouve cet épisode qui
est vraiment relisez le colisée le ces
magnifiques parce que dans le texte vous
savez c'est la femme adultère elle va
être lapidée donc il ya tous les types
qui sont là qui vont la lapider et dans
le texte vous voyez le crée ce qui se
met en dehors du cercle des gens qui
vont lapider cette femme et il se met à
jouer comme ça ils jouent avec le sable
et c'est symbolique du fait qu'ils se
met en dehors de la loi de la cité pour
essayer de faire valoir l'esprit et dit
aux gens au fond mais attendez vous vous
apprêtez à lapider cette femme est
regardée en vous même est ce que vous
êtes vraiment meilleure qu'elle est les
gens se prennent à douter et c'est là
qu'il ya la fameuse phrase que celui qui
n'a jamais péché ces termes on le jette
la première série évidemment en fait
quand on relit ses textes à la lumière
de cette ce fil conducteur qui est la
question des doctrines du salut ça
devient absolument clair et fascinant et
on comprend pourquoi en effet la morale
chrétienne a vaincu pendant des siècles
il ya aussi une autre raison c'est que
l' avantage du christianisme c'est la
résurrection c'est à dire qu'on dit aux
gens non seulement vous allez mourir on
va les ressusciter même chance votre âme
oui on va et votre corps va ressusciter
c'est exactement les gens du c'est que
au fond ce que ce que les grecs
promettait c'est qu'on allait vaincre la
peur de la mort en s'apercevant qu'on
était un petit fragment de cosmos qu'on
était un petit atome de l'univers bon
c'est déjà pas mal mais franchement
quand vous aimez quelqu'un vous avez pas
envie de le retrouver comme fragments de
cosmos vous avez envie de le retrouver
avec sa tête que vous aimez bon
l'organisation d'avoir des garanties si
c'est pour revenir comme acariens dans
la chambre du petit roi
ce que le christ va promettre et c'est
en fait la seule religion qui promet ça
les juifs ne promettent pas les
musulmans ne le premier pas il ya
beaucoup de théories de l'immortalité de
l'âme mais ce que le christ va promettre
c'est la résurrection des corps est
alors évident les gens se sont demandés
mais attend on va remettre mais avec
quelle tête à quel âge c'est un vrai
problème est la réponse du christ au
fond pour le dire simplement c'est la
réponse suivante on va renaître avec le
visage de l'amour c'est avec la tête
qu'on a aimé vous souvenez quand vous
bougez pas des gens sont morts vous
souvenez du visage qu'ils avaient quand
vous les aimez et c'est ça que vous
allez retinne super promesses en même
temps là bas ça a marché
moi j'y crois pas mais je trouve ça
quand même très très beau c'est dur d'y
croire mais c'est dur d'y croire et bien
c'est marie cardini croit par exemple
mais moi je n'y crois pas et un schisme
dans le couple attend heureusement sinon
on s'ennuierait mais mercer
vivement
alors on continue on continue après
après le christianisme quel humanisme
alors là c'est la révolution
scientifique copernic newton des cartes
galilée et l'homme prend la place de
dieu 1 on est on est on est dans un
monde finalement du bien commun de
l'universel qui se passe autour de la
révolution scientifique en gros entre le
16ème 17ème 18ème siècle c'est que à la
fois le monde ancien le cosmos des grecs
cet ordre merveilleux que je décrivais
tout à l'heure il va s'écrouler pour un
tas de raisons qui sont compliqués que
je vais pas raconter là et en même temps
la naissance de la science moderne va
faire peser un doute aussi sur la
religion de l'art en particulier sur la
religion chrétienne et donc les humaine
cette époque là ils vont se retrouver
sans aucune réponse à cette fameuse
question du salut et donc ils vont être
obligés d'inventer une nouvelle réponse
c'est la fameuse phrase de pascal le
silence de ces espaces infinis m'effraie
les parce que le monde qui était comme
une maison qui était une petite niche
que les grecs habitait eh bien il a volé
en éclats sous les coups de la science
moderne et ils vont re fondé à la fois
la science la morale et de nouvelles
doctrines du salut sur l'humanité
offense avec nos droits de l'homme
grillades et une façons ce avec
l'humanisme moderne et c'est aussi
évidemment une très très grande réponse
aussi à la question du salut alors ça ça
a été longtemps indépassable jusqu'à ce
qu'arrive nietzsche il est post moderne
celle là c'est le début la
déconstruction parce que une fois que
vous développer l'esprit critique ce cas
la science va faire elle va développer
l'esprit critique puisqu'elle va
critiquer les visions ancien du monde
elle va critiquer les religions est donc
cette science elle va développer un
formidable esprit critique mais c'est
comme l'acide ça s'arrête pas facilement
l'esprit critique une fois que vous avez
lancé la machine critique eh bien on va
aussi critiqué les grands idéaux que
l'humanisme avait construit les droits
de l'homme la démocratie et nietzsche il
a une phrase merveilleuse il dit il faut
que les idéaux apprennent ce qu'il en
coûte d'avoir des pieds d'argile c'est à
dire des pieds fragiles et il dit moi je
vais philosopher au marteau c'est ce
qu'il appelle la déconstruction déjà il
va casser ce qu'il appelle les ide où
les idéaux de la métaphysique classique
pour se dire au fond le message de la
philosophie c'est d'abord de
déconstruire toutes les illusions
consolatrice dans les gens dépressifs
c'est pas à conseiller la lecture
non mais vous dites parce que ils
étaient très amoureux d'une femme
merveilleuse qu'elle que beaucoup de
gens ont aimé qu'ils étaient lou salomé
qui parait-il était absolument sublime
on était un peu fou nietzsche parce
qu'il l'a rencontrée un soir à rome et
il la demande en mariage il a en
comptera neuf heures du soir et la
demande en mariage à 11 heures donc
évidemment elle lui dit on met deux
heures ce qu'on est et là elle un peu la
trouille suisse qu'est ce que tipi un
peu transpirant pas très beau qui va me
sauter dessus dont mais après il emmène
en voyage
il ya des lettres magnifique où il dit
qui voudrait bien lui raconter à quel
point sa philosophie et comme de l'acide
à quel point et l'aider constructrice à
quel point ils cassent les illusions et
les réponses faciles à la question du
salut mais que comme ils l'aiment
vraiment il hésite à lui faire du mal
parce que c'est vrai que sa philosophie
et et terriblement corrosive mais en
même temps bon c'est une philosophie
absolument magnifique aussi est faux de
l'examen biennal avec une source a
aujourd'hui la philosophie contemporaine
poursuit le travail de déconstruction
entamée par nietzsche althusser lacan
foucault deleuze derrida alors c'est
vrai qu'à la différence de l'époque des
lumières aujourd'hui on va penser qu' on
va vers le mieux qu'est-ce qui est mort
aussi c'est la notion de progrès
ce qui s'est passé si vous vous laissez
pas tellement que le progrès est mort
vous savez bien tous ici que chaque
année nos téléphones portables sont plus
performants et même si vous regardez la
médecine des choses plus sérieuses ça
progresse tous les jours mais ce qui a
changé par rapport au xviiie siècle
c'est que au xviiie siècle on était
convaincu encore dans l'humanisme que
nice va critiquer que le progrès allait
finalement que le progrès des sciences
aller à la fois émanciper les humains et
les rendent plus heureux et est ce que
ce que nietzsche va évidemment kcc cette
croyance au progrès cette croyance naïve
et ce qui se passe aujourd'hui là où il
a d'une certaine façon raison c'est que
bien sûr nous progressons tous les jours
en un sens sur le plan technique mais
plus personne n'est absolument certain
que le progrès est un progrès donc on
n'est pas absolument certain qu'on est
plus libre et plus joueur a des retours
de qui
exemple tu vois il ya des trucs qui vont
pas et donc on a le sentiment que bon
d'accord on va acheter des voitures plus
performante des téléphones portables
puis tu mens mais que c'est pas
forcément plus de liberté plus de
bonheur donc il ya un progrès mais en
même temps la vraie crise du progrès
c'est la question est ce que le progrès
est un progrès car les personnes n'en ai
absolument certain c'est ça qui va
finalement être le grand ébranlement du
20e siècle
je suis allé je
réaction
c'est d'oublier cette loi
bienvenue philo express
attention l'homme est il responsable de
tout ce qu'il fait oui hélas tout
pouvoir s'accompagne t-il de violence
non j'ai fait-il d'être poli envers
autrui pour le respecter non mais c'est
vraiment un premier pas important la
nature fait bien les choses non il ya
laurent baffie en trouvent
ces biens suffit-il de constater pour
atteindre la vérité non pas du tout la
liberté se définit-elle comme un pouvoir
de refuser en grande partie oui notre
liberté de penser at elle des limites on
va te donner
peut-on être libre sans être responsable
non suffit-il d'être dans son droit pour
avoir raison non plus la morale
s'apprend tel
un tout petit peu pas beaucoup l'amour
peut-il être un devoir non surtout pas
elle somme vient de perdre ses illusions
oui quand même
peut-on être sûr d'avoir raison
non les différences sont telles des
inégalités non non bien sûr que non la
liberté consiste t elle à faire ce qui
nous plaît non plus à la recherche de la
vérité peut-elle se passer du doute non
plus peut-on rester un philosophe en
venant la télévision oui évidemment et
enfin ce que sucer c'est tromper
vettier des philosophies m
jeune génération des fissures
chez vous
oui car les trois quarts dans la carte
[Musique]
aïe aïe aïe alors la dernière fois
j'étais à côté d'une jeune femme
charmante
j'ai tiré un truc c'était embrasser
votre voisine donc j'espérais de devoir
vous devez dire du mal de votre films ou
livres ou disques tombeau cas que des
lieux -
oui j'entends dire du mal c'est vraiment
moi qui les critiquent les rares chez
les 5 politique mais l'annoncé avait
délivré caroline et alors
ils ont du mal pour voir rami avant dire
du mal moi j'ai la chance de vivre avec
un homme qui m'a tout appris justement
qui m'a appris il s'ingénie donc
il faut
est ce que l'amour rend aveugle
depuis les hauts faits parfois oui ça a
l'airé c'est un génie mais sous les
ponts mais bien tous les deux là elle
est pas mal
non mais je suis toujours amoureux - il
n'y a rien à faire là je souhaitais pas
mal non plus tu sais au bas c'est gentil
à toi mais bon philosophe
j'ai bien lu patrick boulet et françois
berléand
[Musique]
transports
bonsoir un nouvel album non le nouvel
album c'est dans un mois non mars qui
reviendra mais là ce soir est bien trop
film de chabrol avec françois berléand
ça s'appelle l'ivresse du pouvoir
seulement ce film qui traite pas
directement de l' affaire elf mais qui
s'en inspire largement alors le pitch
c'est isabelle huppert qui est juge
d'instruction et qui est chargée
d'enquêter sur une affaire de
détournements de fonds mettant en cause
le président d'un important groupe
industriel
elle va découvrir l'ivresse du pouvoir
et la tristesse de sa vie privée voilà
évidemment on pense et arriva jolie
alors eva joly a dit en sortant du film
qu'elle a un sentiment de nausée des
taux courant de ça
dans quel sens non j'étais pas au
courant mais dans quel sens ces gars là
vaut
rien à voir avec le fait rire ça faisait
deux trois jours qu'elle n'était pas
bien
elle avait la nausée
revivre des moments difficiles ou est ce
qu'elle avait la nausée de se voir
caricaturé comme ça alors qu'un culture
elle pense qu'elle a fait un travail
vraiment efficace qu'elle a envoyé plein
de gens au tribunal qu'elle s'est donné
du mal ekland a l'impression que ça se
passe un peu comme ça par dessus la
jambe est pas contente eva joly non tu
savais ce à quoi je sers elle cherche
partout et à mon nom ils cherchent pas
tout
peut-être qu'elle s'attendait à un film
façon costa gavras ou michael moore ou
si c'est vrai que ça à en avoir c'est
pas assez pas un film d' enquête quoi
est-ce que l'exactitude même du
traitement de la sphère est important
mais on s'en fout en fait moi je trouve
que dans ce film on n'apprend rien sur
l' affaire elf c'est même encore un peu
plus compliqué quand on sort que quand
on rentre en revanche c'est un
merveilleux festival d'acteurs quoi il
ya eu peur évidemment dont on suit sur
le visage et à travers ses gestes la
prise de conscience progressive de son
pouvoir jusqu'à ce qu'elle fasse la
couverture de paris match on voit bien
que c'est la petite juge qui d'un seul
coup comment ça un plus sentir quoi dire
elle dit à un moment le juge
d'instruction est la personne la plus
importante en france il ya bruel en
grand manipulateur qui balancent les
dirigeants du groupe avant de partir
avec 34 millions d'euros sans avoir
commis la moindre exactions en plus il
est passé pour un con à peu près pendant
tout le temps de cette affaire et il a
manipulé tout le monde il sait bien est
vrai très bien les garder a laissé bien
des mains un grand coup de joueurs de
poker c'est un grand honneur c'est là là
c'est bien un trade lui c'est vraiment
un grand jour c'est un grand joueur on
est des petits-enfants à côté de chez un
mec sans vergogne sans fidélité
très imbu de lui-même très suffisante
comprenez quand même le risque dans ce
film patrick d'un un personnage assez
antipathique quand même j'adore ouais
c'est bien ouais je m'étais amusé déjà
faire un type pas très pas très
fréquentable dans lobo le film de miguel
courtois oui c'est vrai je faisais un
des membres actifs de t a alors il avait
lu père il ya patrick bruel et puis à
les crapules et les crapules sont
extraordinaires il yad'abord berléand
plus vrai que nature en le floch prigent
mais c'est une crapule aussi un revenons
au film
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la même barbe la même barre à cause du
psoriasis voilà c'est ça c'est que
j'avais 5 ans vous avez dit non mais
vous avez du psoriasis vous enfin
le floch prigent son toubib lui a dit de
se laisser pousser la barbe à cause du
psoriasis voilà il serait ce que nous
avons même doubi ben ouais ah ben tu
vois mais moi c'était pour double
manquait donc il m'a dit tu es toi
pousser la barbe ouais parce qu'il a dit
aussi à la fois le présent pour son
psoriasis personnage étonnant
ce type qui n'a pas fait l'ena qui n'a
rien à voir avec tous les autres quoi
qui est une espèce d'autodidacte qui
était arrivé au sommet et qui finalement
trouve naturel de se servir de la carte
de crédit de la société parce qu'après
tout il est dans le public donc c'est
moins bien payés que dans le privé donc
voilà il vient du privé lui un ouais
c'était un grand patron on en droit est
privé donc à partir du moment où ils
entrent dans le public
les émoluments était beaucoup moins
important
il servait de la carte de l'entreprise
pour arrondir ses fins de mois pour
acheter un appartement à sa maîtresse ou
à laçage quoi quelques robes voilà c'est
vrai que c'est bon la comique quelques
manifestations mais enfin il a servi de
fusible par rapport aux politiques alors
incroyable assurance au début du film on
le voit partir en week-end s'occupant
tout même même du fait que les oreillers
pourrait être allergique est et à la fin
on le voit dans un couloir d'hôpital sur
un fauteuil roulant comme une épave
comme ça c'était assez poignant quand je
lis le premier plan est ce que c'est
vrai que c'est un plan séquence on le
voit tout en haut d'une tour à la
défense
et puis pour l'ascenseur il descend
rez-de-chaussée et en fin de compte il
descend on s'est arrêté c'est bien et à
la fin il est pitoyable quoi mais c'est
vrai c'est ma vie un sortie
tu le fais bien je dis tu le fais bien
j'ai très très humain en même temps oui
voilà c'est ça c'est ça qui est drôle de
ces clubs personnages restent
profondément humain ouais alors que les
autres sont vraiment franchement
détestable attends je vais les cités
parce qu'ils sont extraordinaires ces
acteurs loria jean françois balmer il ya
jacques boudet il ya philippe duclos il
ya pierre vernier et ya roger dumas et
flamands qui joue le rôle de roland
dumas puis quand même très ironique de
la part de chabrol ils sont
extraordinaires c'est acté il ya une
galerie de portraits absolument
incroyable jean françois balmer est une
une scène absolument rien dans
d'anthologie j'aimerais moi ils seront
des merveilles il est fort ce chabrol à
il est très fort et oui je sais il sait
parfaitement où il va un départ et il
sait parfaitement où vous emmener au
mensonge à brax alors on va voir à quoi
ça ressemble je les regardais votre
caméra tous les deux et vous allez dire
magnéto serge un mâle de 2 3 magnéto
serge bien
bonjour monsieur le président jeanne
charmant killman je suis chargé
d'instruire votre dossier qu'est ce que
vous voulez procéder votre mise en
examen pour abus de biens sociaux abus
de confiance présentation de comptes
inexacts
dès 9h30 c'est une perquisition
vous acharnez voit comme moi vous êtes
le numéro un du conte russe le président
enfin c'est normal vous ouvrez le ban
j'interrogerai numéro 2 et numéro 3 puis
ainsi de suite vous habiller une femme
de la tête aux pieds et vous connaissez
pas le prix je suis désolé madame c'est
pas ma faute si votre mari a une double
vie vous êtes signifie connais qui ont
fait des choses autrement plus graves
que moi cette juge d'instruction
infernal a continué de chercher des poux
ils ont trafiqué frais la direction du
fonds peut-être forme et géraient
jusqu'au
regard de nous tourner deux fantômes qui
se croise de temps en temps dans un
appartement sur leye j'suis qui pour toi
je suis cuit
[Musique]
c'est en mairie tous ces récits jeunes
du service
c'est juste ce n'est pas possible elle
ne comprend rien règles du jeu ce ne
sont pas mes amis à en avoir et que
c'est con mais j'aimais d'amgen
je te conseille de prendre un peu de
vacances je veux absolument aucun
problème pour ta prime je ferai le
nécessaire chez toi une paire de
couilles avec
sasson je renoncerai jamais
parce que c'est comme ça
chabrol avec isabelle huppert
tatibouët les françois berléand nous
sommes les invités ce soir voilà
c'est la première fois tous les deux
vous tournez avec chabrol écoutons
ensemble ouais mais alors c'est bien ah
oui malheureusement on n'a pas de scènes
ensemble alors donc c'est françois qui
vous a mis sur le coup donc c'est un peu
par hasard c'est françois qui m'a parlé
de ce2 ce2 ce film en me disant qu'il
allait tourner avec chabrol et je dis à
moi j'adore chabrol j'adore son travail
je n'ai jamais rencontré c'est vrai que
tu as dis ça mais moi je dis
ça comme vous étiez à la baule et vous
avez déjeuné avec chabrol voilà voilà à
l'océan un petit bar en croûte de sel et
voilà à l'intérieur c'est un blanc un
petit air d'opéra et voilà
il me suis retrouvé dans dans l'
aventure dans l'aventuré chabrol voilà
une aventure qui a commencé depuis si
longtemps il ya une île à une grande
fidélité que j'aime et qui travaille ça
c'est on arrive dans une petite famille
dans un sens c'est bien c'est très très
chouette vous avez plus de chances qu
avec steven spielberg parce qu'il paraît
qui vous a appelés pour munir qu'elle
m'a pas plu il appeler votre agent ils
ont paraît-il qu'on a appelé mon
appareil iphone appelé mon agent et que
je sais ça fait un peu trop parce que
mon agent m'a dit que t'es pas libre de
votre agent a dit que vous étiez las
vegas c'est vrai mais las vegas et la
carte à 40 minutes de los angeles aurait
été plus facile est vrai mais j'étais
pas j'étais pas et c'est pas grave c'est
quoi l'adage ou
non peu importe sur le moment c'était un
peu dur à vivre de se dire je vais pas
faire le casting d'un film aussi
important oui parce que ce film me
paraissait très important lors elle
s'est
séparée me paraissait utile et puis
tourner avec spielberg et puis tout ça à
pied et puis et puis et puis l'a vu le
film puis j'ai déjà vu le film oui je
suis finalement c'est pas si grave ils
ont pris quelques solides saddam place
remarquable et surnom surtout ils ont
pris le match mathieu amalric et mathieu
amalric
mais comme j'ai beaucoup de doutes quant
aux propos du film voilà je suis pas
mécontent de eu finalement de paillettes
mais mais bon comme j'ai envie de faire
un jour un film avec spielberg veut pas
dire ce que je pense je suis là mais
vous vous connaissez tous les d'exister
dans mon idole a démarré femme a bien
sûr mais c'était bien ça un lapin
c'était magnifique le bon vieux temps et
oui c'était bon vieux temps un oui de
belfort parce qu'il a perdu
alors commencé avec bruel c'est vraiment
bien peut-être avoir cédé points communs
avec bruel a à priori comme ça non mais
quoi que je chante
l'hymne terrain comme patrick
françois est ce que comme patrick bruel
vous avez couché avec plus de 1000
femmes
alors hop un petit peu moi un petit peu
moins thibaut monnet l'est beaucoup
moins ouais est ce que comme patrick
bruel vous rêvez que quand vous mangez
une pizza sur les champs elysées les
femmes se jettent sur vous non je ne
mange pas de pizza je déteste les pizzas
au merlotte's attend non plus je déteste
ah ben voilà bah comme connaissent comme
patrick bruel est resté sympa malgré
deux succès
ouais enfin j'ai pas encore le succès de
patrick un pays est beaucoup moins sympa
je suis vraiment sympa
cécile comme patrick bruel vous auriez
rêvé d'être footballeur ah ouais
ah oui est ce que comme patrie bref j'ai
trouvé la femme de votre vie oui parce
que tu en as marre de cette nana là
vers les hôpitaux alors berléand il peut
pas rester célibataire ah c'est vrai
c'est assez marrant toi mais c'est comme
ça
la conjugalité j'aime la conjugalité
ouais même si la conjugalité tu le
couple ouais tu le sais que tu aimes le
français jacques tuer le couple j'aime
tuer le père j'ai tué mon père déjà juin
mais non non je ne peux pas vivre ça
mais c'est impossible tu sais que diane
est célibataire en ce moment
c'est ce que tu pourras tu es bon tu es
célibataire
et baptiste avait pas l'air malheureux
non mais c'est vrai t'as l'air
malheureuse le soir bah non je suis pas
mal je m'attendais pas non plus tout de
même gênant pour les caennais
est ce que tous ces militaires
c'est toujours est ce que comme patrick
bruel s'est parfois envie de vous casser
la voix je me casse la voit
régulièrement tu chantes non je joue tu
sais chanter non comme patrick bruel
annoncé
[Applaudissements]
jean tu adores dix ans les gens n'ont
aucun doute
dégâts côté ri tellement à tes valises
ont aucun goût la
tps comme patrick bruel vous êtes un peu
complexés par vos bourrelets
moitié fou quoi c'est qu'elle roulait
je n'ai aucun bourrelet arrêt comme
celle très bien j'ai simplement petit
peu de ventre n'est pas de brûler papa
le ton sexe
et je t'emmerde
pourquoi vous applaudissez
est ce que comme patrick bruel vous êtes
super fort au poker non non non non
malheureusement je sais que j'aime bien
jouer au poker mais je ne suis pas aussi
fort que lui il est très fort mais très
très très fort je joue très bien
philippe rondot s'en fout en chaîne
comme patrick bruel psg
étudie marseille marseille marseille
open qu'il a
non
[Musique]
alors patrie vous avez déclaré rld a
beau aimer sa compagne sa mère son frère
et son cousin on ne découvre ce qu'est
véritablement l'amour que quand on a un
enfant
ouais c'est vrai moi je pense que son
sentiment assez particulier je crois
qu'on a deux sentiments de sentiments
très très fort quand un enfant c'est
vous connaissez pas avant l'amour parce
que je pense que voit jamais mais avant
on croit qu'on aimait vraiment aimé
avant et a peur ouais n'ont jamais eu
peur comme ça non je n'ai plus jamais
comme avant après quand on a des enfants
on a toujours peur qu'il arrive quelque
chose c'est vrai c'est vrai les tient de
fait où ils sont là les gîtes à porte de
la chapelle
s'est débrouillé pour
l'argent
sans parler des années aux parents leur
machine à bout dit patrick les autres
vous le disent mais vous comprenez
vraiment ce que c'est le jour où ça vous
arrive oui oui c'est vrai ils vont bien
ce caméléon ça se passe bien elles
prennent un prénom il assiège eeel envie
de s'en sortir
on va faire une interwiew papa poule
alors pas fait est-ce qu'il vous est
arrivé de changer les couches de vos
enfants même quand il y avait du caca
c'est vrai oui je chanterai coupe non
mais ça va tu fais ça je suis arrivé non
mais jane lynch et admiratif mois bon il
n'ya pas d'admiration à voir il ya des
gens qui pour qui c'est naturel d'autres
pour qui ça l'est pas il croit qu'elle
peut pas juger moi c'est instantané tout
de suite été levée la nuit pour les
biberons je me lève toutes les nuits
surtout en ce moment tu chante des
berceuses à ses enfants mais j'ai
regardé les teletubbies oui ça y est on
est passé à autre chose du genre ah oui
est ce que tu as déjà fait aucune union
pas tellement pas tellement pas
tellement j'ai là j'ai peut-être eu la
folie de penser que ce n'est en fait
qu'un enfant très très très très bas âge
vous comprends parfaitement d'accord
donc dès l'âge de cinq jours je suis
quand même déjà tué les et du fort lui
disait tu sais je sais combien papa il
paye comme urssaf par mois il
responsabilisait
mais bon peut-être peut-être peut-être à
tort
est ce que tu vas au parc le dimanche
après midi et qui me poussait à trois
roues
oui non pas le dimanche après midi mais
oui plutôt les éléments semaine tu
dragues quand tu es au park hyatt je
pense car il mieux est ce que tu as déjà
perdu le doudou de ton enfant j'ai cru
leur peuple mais non kroll je n'ai pas
pu me rassure je n'ai pas perdu est ce
que tu as déjà oublié ton enfant quelque
part non
al adha à
ses records plus pratique j'ai regretté
d'avoir eu ses enfants à un moment tu
sais bien pour le gosse pour l'éducation
toile et on je te regrette tu comprends
ça je ne veux pas de toi jamais à aucun
moment tu t'es dit quelle connerie j'ai
fait jamais non alors je sais pas je me
renseigne
tu penses que rien n'est plus beau que
le sourire d'un enfant vient ainsi de 2
tu les as pas fait pour faire plaisir à
la mer tu les as fais aussi pour toi pas
aussi pour moi d'accord
déjà caressé les jetons enfants en
pensant l'économie d'impôt que cette
faisait faire
voilà demi page
vous aurez des gosses et jean alesi
claquer le pognon bien voulu que ce soit
une demi part mais mais pas du tout non
tu conduis plus prudemment maintenant
que tu es un enfant oui tu avais peur qu
un jour ton fils écoute du lorie
non non et non parce que
ma meilleure en fils et coûtera écoutera
coutras qui m'a qui lui sera ce qui lui
sera proposé dès beaucoup de choses dues
seront proposés donc ça va
est ce que le fait d'avoir eu des
enfants tout à fait perdre des potes
non le fait d'avoir des enfants fait
qu'il ya d'autres choses que tu fais
moins il ya des gens que tu vois moins
il ya des way et les choix à faire quand
même fait il s'impose des choix ouais il
ne chante pas douloureux
non non non il n'ya pas ya ben non c'est
tellement incroyable
tu as l'impression que tu es vieux
m'adapte à des mondes
non c'est exact c'est une bonne question
mais ça mais c'est pas là c'est pas la
bonne question et j'ai l'impression que
je
j'aurais pu pour toi que j'ai compté le
temps ouais d'avoir avant je ne comptais
pas way they all à 13
soit berléand et ses sorties mais les
messieurs
chabrol
[Musique]
g
chez moi y'en a que trois
ils avaient habitués double carte des
cartes encore les heures scirocco je
vais reprendre l'accent pieds noirs de
vos débuts
c'est à dire tu m'as pris vraiment pour
un convoi
de toi car
sans génie
attention une retenue de 50 cartes parce
que je suis plus vieux que toi mon en
est un gros paquet lui au nom
du bon lait l'afrique passe et comment
ça détend vous devrez affronter mon
garde du corps un free fight c'est à
dire celle libre combat libre kambire
tous les coups sont permis celle qu'elle
le garde de corps de qui régissent
comment ils n vert du corps régime
je me souviens
c'est moi
j'y vois là je vois déjà tapé une mycose
bravo à
moi c'est plus haut à ces salles alors
qu'est-ce qui va pas
un problème
lorsque savez ce qu'il a dit le problème
il est toujours péter le braille a mal
au bras tu tapes l'eau tu tapes l'autre
l'autre ok doucement alors doucement à
lésé pourquoi tu veux prendre une rouste
et tfou cette voie là qu'est ce que
c'est ça la qualité
je dois l'affronter alors bon add on
souhaite une très bon soir et il y
allume le donc alors régis tu feras pas
comme ça d'accord ce qui là qu'est ce
qu'il fait comme la couture c'est son
pseudo
oui alors voilà donc c'est la première
chose
la bd chez vous c'est gênant ce qui veux
pas me faire
pas par là
euros
[Musique]
j'étais comme ça il était comme ça c'est
comme ça il a vu qui était le maître et
que ce soit la dernière et
tu sais quoi c'est que tu as failli et
dans la bande du splendid au départ au
départ oui mais s'est fait recaler à
cause de temps pulsé qu'on
appelle et d'époque
écoute le service est coûteux fait très
attention tout ça parce que j'ai pas
voulu faire ton film de merde
tu aurais pu être qu'on a entendu ce
qu'ils ont envie de venir en rigolo lui
devenir un acteur sérieux et avait
toutes les qualités aussi un ouais mais
déjà des arthroses à l'époque
complètement le bon dieu a fait guère qu
est ce que ça marche ça incroyable j'ai
fait douze films par an non c'est ça
ouais mais aucun
cas n'a aucun effet les bronzés le
shield est bon si l asus eee quand même
et testeur chez quick
finalement c'est bon lance
éventuellement c'est beau non ce cas
c'est que effectivement si gvt si
j'avais intégré la bande du splendid
peut-être la réponse sinon tu vas fermer
ta gueule ou
ça tu démarré plus tôt ça n'aurait plus
tard c'est pas plus mal si t'arrêtes pas
été content oui voilà beaucoup comme une
écoute
j'accueille jacques brillet
comment savamment jean-claude très
élégant oui je finis vent était en
pull-over il va mais je crois
qu'elle exprime briani donc après de
vives autobiographique le ruisseau des
sages et j'ai oublié de vous dire qu'ils
se sont vendus comme un million
d'exemplaires et ça fait des sous oui
enfin ça fait beaucoup pour les impôts
ouais la moitié abandonne jogging comme
un oui mais je mets la maison
souviens
je les mêmes essayer oui c'est trop
large pour toi j'en connais d'autres
c'est pas moi c'est pas moi à ma place
et ça écrit les pièces et des pièces qui
m'a et les thèses qui va attaquer donc
après soixante quinze dates à guichets
fermés du spectacle j'ai oublié de vous
dire et quatre mois aux bouffes
parisiens vous revenez avec un livre
intitulé les pensées des plus grands
actes c'est pas de moi c'est moi j'ai
fait la préface et j'ai choisi avec
quelqu'un les répliques les plus
scintillante pain elles sont bien ce qui
est bien c'est qu'on croit toujours que
les acteurs sont un peu con way alors
c'est bien dans ce qui concer perçoit
que tout de même les acteurs ne sont pas
seulement des perroquets way qui ils ont
de l'esprit et de mouches début tout à
l'heure avec eux ces deux là moi j'adore
les gens qui me font rire il ya là
beaucoup et il y en a une de vous dans
le bouquin non je n'ai une de bruel ou
de berléand normand d'accord l'amérique
des gens très très connus
trésor mais non mais c'est surtout des
gens vendent et qui parle du sexe de
l'amour en avant propos vous dites cité
des pensées des autres c'est souvent
regretté de ne pas les avoir eus soi
même et c'est en prendre un peu la
responsabilité voilà bah oui c'est vrai
que je et quelquefois quelle chance
sacha guitry avait de vivre avec les
gens il déjeunait avec capuche renard au
t1 mirebeau feydeau aujourd'hui on s'en
va un peu plus quoi vrai alors on va
voir si vous vous en souvenez et on va
voir si nos amis savent qu'ils ont sont
les auteurs on y va mon coeur est
français vont qu'un et internationale je
me suis dit bien très bien au procès
c'est une phrase de jean sont ces gens
sans que lui avait écrite pour le procès
sas est hermétique oui trop tard les
les femmes ont besoin d'une raison pour
faire l'amour les hommes ont juste
besoin d'un endroit
vous dirai à l'aide d' harry s'est pas
au dialogue non c'est billy crystal
abonnés cristal oui je dans mafia blues
au
malawi bah oui alors c'est international
sourire vous ce livre est international
d'accord fermer les maisons closes c'est
plus qu'un crime c'est un pléonasme
aletti bien dieu a créé l'alcool pour
que les femmes moches baisse quand même
bien ce jour les shsh coluche coluche
elle est bien ces jeunes la nuit d'amour
avec marilyn j'aurais préféré qu'on ne
le sut ce point si je puis dire alors su
ce point alors
mon temps on dirait même temps si
c'était involontaire après je ne suis
pas un nouveau riche je suis un ancien
collège
il n'y a pas que l'argent dans la vie il
ya aussi des fourrures et les bijoux
la belle femme aussi
elizabeth taylor j'ai compris que le
père noël n'existait pas quand j'avais 5
ans je suis entré dans un grand magasin
il m'a demandé un autographe
petite actrice tempo
c'est un évident
quand on s'est fait connaître en
choquant on ne peut plus choqué quand le
choc en plus
luc ferry
a une qui vient le soir des oscars
j'étais entouré de femmes qui n'arrêtait
pas de me demander je peux la toucher
malheureusement elle parlait de la
statue est
bel et bien
le travail d'équipé est essentielle en
cas d'erreurs ça permet d'accuser
quelqu'un d'autre génieau non un mec que
tu adores tu le cites schéma pourquoi
l'armée mais oui
[Rires]
haye et bien vous avez beaucoup
d'ennemis oui comme tous les gens qui
n'aiment pas les cons
pas mal dit tri dans l'avenir
l'expérience est un peine que vous donne
la vie quand vous êtes devenu chauve lié
blier encore vous savez ce que c'est la
connerie imaginez une plage le soleil à
whisky avec des glaçons des nanas autour
de vous vous y êtes et bien tout le
reste c'est de la connerie
j'aime beaucoup la cuisine chinoise mon
plat préféré c'est le numéro 27 mondial
jim carrey
c'est bien ce que c'est il ya trois
choses dans la vie que je supporte pas
le café brûlant le champagne qu'elle est
femme froide
orson welles j'ai jamais été très
optimiste à tel point que j'ai toujours
hésité abonnés pour plus d'un an un
magazine c'est moi hassan dutronc
mais une autre de jim carrey qui est
vachement il est bon de jim carrey je
savais pas quand on parle à dieu c'est
une prière quand c'est lui qui nous
parle c'est la schizophrénie
woody allen l'a justement le côté
positif de la mort c'est qu'on peut
l'être en restant couchés
et une de pierre doris qu'on salue ici à
ja rule qui est moins des fans de pierre
doris tous les morts ont de la chance
ils ne voient leur famille qu'une fois
par an à la toussaint
un millionnaire c'est un milliardaire
qui vient de payer ses impôts
faire l'amour et la dernière le point
commun entre tous les hommes que j'ai
aimé c'est moi jeanne moreau jeanne
moreau bravo
[Applaudissements]
jean compris
les pensées et plus drôle des acteurs
c'est publié on cherchait
c et bien vivre qu'il faut avoir ça
ça se lit vite et puis c'est on s'en
souvient 11 qui a répète on va aller
briller dans les dîners après voilà
quand on est un peu peu qu'on vous êtes
là vous pourriez nous dire quelques mots
sur darry cowl vous qui paraît tellement
bien des morts pour moi il est vivant
encore
ma j'ai la chance de mon premier film
nous est fait avec lui c'était l'ami de
la famille et les beautés genre à
l'autre et panther le treport patrie
potter triporteur c'était après mais
c'était un il était plein de c'est un
lutin c'était un enfant il jouait
beaucoup carte au casino ils adorent et
les femmes il était amoureux de béatrice
altarriba mais amoureux comme un
étudiant comme un enfant ils portaient
des fleurs et acheter des petits cadeaux
des bagues il était délicieux parce que
il tremblait pour lui tu voulais lui
plaire alors il a pesé rire beaucoup
c'est ce qu'il est sa presse après ces
passes déduction je crois que jusqu'au
bout de sa vie il a fait croire à sa
femme qu'il est éternel ce qu est la
plus belle preuve d'amour
[Applaudissements]
ça nous arrivera à tous on en parlait
tout à l'heure avec luc ferry le jour où
ça vous arrivera qui souhaitez-vous pour
faire votre éloge funèbre et bien je
vais vous dire un jour j'étais à
l'enterrement comme par hasard
j'étais godet de long il me prend la
main et me dit 'il morgan d'abi violent
il me dit c'est moi qui parlerai quand
tu seras mort alors je lis mais pour moi
ça serais toi et moi je parle pas de toi
c'est est mort dit non parce que c'est
comme ça donc je pense que ces deux
longues ses talents qui s'y collera
médina parlera bien parce qu'ils
m'aiment bien enfin je veux dire que je
suis très heureux que mes camarades
tournage chabrol parce que c'est
vraiment un personnage qui connaît donc
c'est lui qui m'a donné ma 20 et au
cinéma et c'est un personnage poétique
complètement délirant et et en conduite
dans arrête de dire qu'il aime bien
bouffer les citoyens fonction des
restaurants il aime surtout les actrices
dans les acteurs et il est même les
étoiles et en foot il y les cousins bret
un film donné envie de faire ce métier
avec ce film le beau serge d'ailleurs
ses sorties ses sorties consenti
mercredi avec la marge est très fort ça
marche très fort oui très très fort il a
eu peur c'est quelqu'un comme disait
gamin parce que c'est pas dans le livre
méga baptisé je tourne toujours avec des
acteurs de première comme ça je me mets
en surmultipliée et la hubert et les
tensions mutins et fort qu'il ya autour
d'elle des grands grands comédiens c'est
ce qu'on va faire maintenant une
interview au camp
jean-claude vous trouvez pas que les
jeunes acteurs ne respecte plus assez
leurs aînés ont respecté c'est pas très
amusant je préférais qu'il les aime où
tous les packs je suis pas de votre
temps les actrices s'habiller pas tout
comme des filles de petite vertu
aujourd'hui connu quand j'étais jeune
oui mais c'est bien petite vertu dre pas
qu'avant n'ai pas besoin d'effets
spéciaux pour un film spectaculaire
oui c'est vrai que quand on les enfants
du paradis les effets spéciaux c'était
prévert way serait pas que les
spectateurs maintenant au cinéma ils ont
pu de manière aiguë du pop corn et si le
move à l'anthrax ah bah ouais c'est vrai
que c'est dommage de voir disparaître
toutes ses salles de cinéma oui ça c'est
triste les multiplexes moi j'aime
beaucoup les pieds de sa à l'oreille
c'est un souvenir d'enfance quoi tout
est pas qu'un film en dvd ça remplacera
jamais un film dans une salle quand même
aller au cinéma c'est une cérémonie
d'une fête
vous serez pas qu'avant les journalistes
il respectait les acteurs il se prenait
pas pour des stars
non parce que j'ai connu un journaliste
important qui a dit du mal des enfants
du paradis donc tout le monde peut se
tromper ouais elle lui on sait plus qui
il est ouais ouais serait pas que la
télévision a tué le cinéma finalement et
qu'on sait pas comment ça se terminera
pour elle non parce que la télévision
fait des films de télévision il ya une
différence entre les films de télévision
et les films de cinéma soit pas que le
scénario actuellement beaucoup moins
d'intérêt quand même
non parce qu'il ya des gens qui est
quand même très très beau scénario vous
savez j'ai pas encore vu le film de
chabrol mais je vais y aller demain mais
j'ai vu le fauteuil d'orchestre est un
beau film de table danièle thompson a
construit bien écrit non je trouve dit
triste un peu aujourd'hui que les rôles
secondaires disparaissent ouais quand je
suis arrivé à txema ya donc cinquante
ans pour moi pauline carton jean tissier
carette daliot jules berry étaient des
vedettes
aujourd'hui il ya des vedettes il ya
moins d'acteurs romande rsr il y en a
plein non mais c'est pas les allées des
rôles secondaires c'est une troupe mais
art et il m'avait dit dans leur hôtel du
nord elle m'avait dit le jouet moines a
tourné huit jours dans hôtel du nord
annabella jean pierre aumont cette
semaine on se souvienne qui s'est
très pas que le cinéma est mort avec
françois truffaut
non il a il a été malade parce que quand
on soit un parti il a manqué quelques
uns au cinéma mais il yad'autres
françois truffaut qui arrive très pas
qu'une star en jeans et une faute de
goût quand même
pas une star qu'est ce que c'est qu'une
star moi j'aime beaucoup les légendes
j'ai connu par l'inde est riche de
daggar beau elle faisait rêver parce
qu'elles savaient des déshabillés qui
faisait plus penser à beaucoup de choses
qui étaient plus érotique que de
déchirer humblot jean trouve pas que la
promo c'est pénible en plus vous parler
de sa vie privée tout côte est avec vous
mon cher c'est à bonn or
les français
alors c'est publié au cherche midi de la
fête
un deux trois quarts
il ya des moments où je me demande si je
vais pas changer et que je vais pas
venir normal quand je vois les jeunes
filles pareil enfin bon on n'est pas
allé au salon du jeu steam vous avez
quatre cartes
il faut dire qu'une suis pas seule la
carte senior ça tombe bien vous avez
droit à une couverture pour vos jambes
si vous le désirez
chauffante à l'effort aller au coin tout
de suite
c alors
c'est alors ouais ouais ouais
non
ça me revient
bien bas je te laisse filer tu vas
mettre chapeau était déjà ce soir aux
partenaires voire 1 vous partez
vous êtes fiancée non elle est libre
ça va être à toi à bientôt dia
j'accueille amel bent
[Applaudissements]
bon
alors pour tous ceux qui ne
connaîtraient pas à wendel amène band
c'est ça je n'ai qu'une
[Musique]
je suis
pas
moi
m
[Musique]
et
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'adore cette chanson
si j'ai acheté le single allez jean
claude tout seul
non mais j'ai remarqué qu'ils avaient
beaucoup de jeune fille qui chante et ça
c'est sympathique un tube énorme c'est
écrit par diam's c est toi ces extraits
de ton premier album qui s'appelle un
jour d'été et le résultat ne s'est pas
fait attendre nommé trois victoires de
musique artiste révélation du public
album révélation et chanson de l'année
voire à
classement 1
brésil
mais par michel drucker nagui voilà
alors michel rocard a dit quel que soit
le résultat
ça sera l'année amel bent
mais si koné va chez michel drucker et
michel en vigueur ni quand même il s'y
connaît ouais même moi je ne connais le
disque finalement perdre à la nouvelle
star c'est la meilleure façon de montrer
son talent je sais pas enfin pour moi
ça a été alors tu as vendu quand même
sept cent mille exemplaires du single
pratiquement 500 milles de l'album ah et
puis c'est pas fini à ça aussi
[Musique]
mais ça l'est pour je
match qui se tourne
et
oh
alors c'est le troisième single
extrait d'un jour d'été pour voir à quoi
ça ressemble je vais regarder ta caméra
la séquelle rouge et tu vas dire magnéto
serge
magnéto serge dia
[Musique]
je serai
m
après
n'est pas
je serai jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà les balles ne retient pas ses
larmes
amères tournée et le 28 mars à l'olympia
le 28 mars à la paix à m françois
berléand y sera oui ah ouais avec son
petit peu
ce sera le printemps tapis pour le
printemps l'intrigué va pas vers un peu
vert d'eau à la elle est belle a un fils
simplement qu'elle serait bien mal
datation des retraites fait joli huawei
alors en fait j'étais prédestiné pour
faire ce métier parce que votre vrai nom
c'est amel bent bachir alors bent
c'est-à-dire filles 2 et bachir ça veut
dire le chant hébreu et amel l'espoir en
arabe donc son vrai nom ses espoirs du
champ c'est assez extraordinaire dans de
nouvelles en voyage je viens à me nation
ouais c'est ça et vous êtes né le 21
juin jour de la fête de la musique on y
voit le jour de l'été voilà oui je
voulais tellement c'est alors que c'est
un printemps voilà je lis ce que je veux
dire là
qu'est ce qui te prends toi et chaud ce
soir ça me reproche à changer ce qui ça
changeait quoi je me mêle pas de jaloux
non mais déjà le titre et des canaux je
suis ému syrie et hautain non mais tu
sais quand on arrive à un certain âge ça
vous revient alors votre maire un salon
de coiffure à villetaneuse ouais c'est
pas elle sait pas elle non elle
travaille de l'appareil ouais enfin
longtemps ah ouais plus pour longtemps
là tu vas t'occuper d'elle
il me les offrir et bien offrir un salon
sema pour femmes ou pour hommes les deux
et devient ainsi très bien géré c'est
très très bien oui vous avez grandi à la
courneuve oui vous êtes assez fier mais
voulait pas devenir la chanteuse et
maghrébins à quoi
même si je suis très fier de mes
origines
je le dis j'ai pas envie de moi à la
droite la gauche mais
ceci étant au moment des émeutes vous
avez
sans cautionner la violence avait
compris la rébellion quand même
franchement
vous dit quand on a une plaque 93 on se
fait toujours arrêter quoi souvent même
soirée
un sentiment de persécution cette
persécution c'est un grand mot mais
ouais je pense que wayne voilà je pense
que c'est vraiment les mentalités
doivent changer en général et pour tout
le monde pas seulement pour les jeunes
aussi des banlieues il faut arrêter
aussi de se sentir persécuté et puis que
les autres arrêtent de parce qu'ils
étaient aussi quand vous dites est un
taxi je vais la courneuve ils veulent
pas vous emmener un an mais une fois je
me vois j'étais à opéra je me suis
assise par terre je me suis mise à
pleurer parce que le au bout du
quatrième taxi maintenant ils voulaient
pas usé la courneuve si je vous paye
avant vous tenez je vous donne un billet
disent non à la cour même de quoi il a
peur benjamin taxi basket
ça fait par la courneuve en espace
et dans les boîtes c'est pareil photo a
pas de problème mais les crises et c'est
un peu plus facile voilà donc du pain
voilà on rentre par toi mais les gars on
va jean claude
je ressens pas adoptée du jeu bon je
vais pour des robes du soir les garçons
c'est un peu difficile je pense
et vous avez parlé à sarkozy quand vous
l'avez rencontrée en fait
partie mais il m'a dit qu'il aimait bien
la chanson et de la chanter un hymne à
chanter l'hymne et en chantant dieu
oui
c'est un peu ça avec des amis à lui et
puis j'y vais vous êtes déjà venu chez
moi on m'a dit ah oui il faut que je dis
bah ouais il m'a dit vous habitez ou
givet à la courneuve
médias qui va vous voyez il n'y a pas
que des voyous des deux locaux l'accueil
qu'on met toi ok c'est des gens qui va
faire sortir des gens de bien et
heureusement c'est une majorité là bas
donc voilà j'espère que la prochaine
fois que vous viendrez bien ce sera pour
autre chose et pouvoir c'est cette
majorité l'a
alors de lui que tu joues à la corde
mais vous avez acheté une maison pour
votre mère votre soeur qui a 12 ans
votre frère qui accueille huit ans et
vous dites d'ailleurs je vais je la
quitterais seulement pour marié quoi et
alors norman bientôt j'espère bach
moussala
quoi j'espère bah ça s'est arrangé là ça
ne s'est jamais arrêté un peu non ah bon
avec qui mais qui pousse à te connais
pas moussa
et dans ta bulle
tu connais pas moussa ndiaye agent
commercial il est pas mal ce mec sympa
parce qu'il est beau oui les boks que
le problème en fait c'est que moussa il
a du mal à accepter ta vie c'est normal
non ça c'est les magazines qui disent ah
bon il a du mal à accepter les magazines
ouais ça c'est vrai tu as bien parce que
c'est pas son métier ouais c'est pas
c'est parce que c'est pas son truc à lui
français pas lui quoi la séparation a
duré quoi quinze jours quoi non il n'y a
pas eu de séparation maintenant si
jamais habiter chez lui fin j
jamais quitté ma maman ouais on entame
elle prend ses cliques et ses claques y
retourne chez sa mère ça c'est pas vrai
voilà tu vois tes heureusement que tu es
là heureusement
pas bon il fait des concessions quand
même maintenant qu'ils moussa
quand nous faire un jour vous l'un vitré
vous lui demanderez mais oui tu hormis
les pas avec toi là ce soir s'il l'a
nous sommes
tous
mon cas
[Musique]
non franchement quoi les oreilles même
pas te laisser travailler il aime pas
beaucoup de catherine tu vois si moussa
peut venir évidemment ça se fait en
foutez lui la paix à mme hussein
qui chantent ils n'ont ils content
d'être dans l'ombre elle est contente
d'être dans la lumière et nous on est
coincé moussa je sais qu'à trier n'est
pas facile je sais oui enfin c'est pas
comme c'est pas comme marie caroline
moussavi 3,4 et il n'a pas les couilles
tu n'as rien à voir
rigolo ça a boosté la vue mouzin
l'impressionnant
bon taf et les restos du coeur l'a alors
oui donc tu es entré dans la chanson
française c'est comme ça c'est comme ça
qu'on a doublé et adoubé maladie ouais à
faire une telle chanson française
concentre toi
est ce que comme joe dassin on t'a déjà
conseil des cif et là haut sur la
colline
des collines à la courneuve y en a pas
beaucoup
est ce que comme eddy mitchell tu te
demandes si tu es racine soit 1h ville
ou à belleville je sais où sont mes
racines je demande pas ouais
moussa
[Musique]
alors c'est des conneries cette histoire
vous n'êtes jamais quittée en fait parce
que la presse a dit que tu te supportait
pas qu'elle soit chanteuse qu'elle soit
jamais light ou tu t'en fous en fait non
franchement y'a pas jamais on sait
jamais quitté ouais j'aime eu de
problème n'est même pas eu quinze jours
de séparation non non non tout va bien
ouais tout va bien tout va très bien
ils sont bien les deux vous allez vous
marier alors
on encore du temps quand on nous verra
et qu'est ce tu fais tes agent
commercial quoi t'es où je suis je
vendais voiture suivant des voitures
voilà un grand inventaire c'est de faire
un enfant j'espère
moi j'en veux plus voir une équipe de
foot voilà
est-ce que comme annie cordy et des
choses que vous aimeriez bien faire mais
que vous pouvez poids
non est
ce que comme carlos vous avez déjà connu
un gros papayou l'ailé qui fait déjà je
suis désolé c'est la question je n'ai
pas eu cette chance et elle est bien la
question
est ce que me téléphone vous rêvez d'un
autre monde où la terre saurait ronde je
pense qu'elle est bien rond de
l'internât ouais
ça te va comme ça je vais peut-être dans
notre monde mais
agit comme charles aznavour on a déjà
dit tu te laisses aller
ouais
des fois quand elle en jogging comme ça
avec les chaussettes et tout va
tellement je les chiffres sur le canapé
est où tu le faisais pas tout et c'est
pas du tout et c'est ya pire ah
ouais c'est vrai je vais tâcher de
bagnères de luchon on s'arrange pour
l'émission mais est ce que le med-it pia
vous pourriez vous train de rembrandt si
je vous le demandez
est ce comme lara fabian vous avez envie
de dire je t'aime
est ce que michel sardou vous regrettez
le temps béni des colonies
non non à mon avis non c'est comme les
rôles et missions ne faisait du mal à
obtenir satisfaction ah non ça va moins
ça va quand on pense qu'ils étaient
séparés n'y a pas qu'un joueur
[Rires]
est ce que comme joey starr vous avez
déjà zoom même dans une benne benz benz
est ce que comme michael jackson vous
pensez que vous êtes mauvaise mauvaise
oui mauvaise mauvaise
est ce que comme un charme et cela vous
pensez que la misère est moins dure au
soleil à fallait demander ça ouais mon
petit africain la va vite comme jacques
brel vous pensez que les bourgeois c'est
comme les cochons
des fois tu sais devient vieux plus ça
devient de cours des mois et c'est comme
georges brassens vous pensez que 95 fois
sur 100 la femme s'emmerde en [__] je
sais pas c'est pas ton cas
je n'ai pas tout mais complet marin
est ce que quand michel polnareff vous
pensez qu'on ira tous au paradis même
mois mais c'est pas à nous de décider
ouais ah ouais tout d'abord qui à part à
dire ouais enfin pour toute l'ambiance
en l'herbe
c'est super
[Musique]
de toi garde
vous devez vous remettre ensemble
jean pierre pernaut vous devez dire
combien vous gagnez en moyenne par mois
aux ébats en fait c'est pas pour moi
qu'on gagne de l'argent écoutons des
fois ya des petits cachets et sinon je
crois que va être la première année
s'est passé ou non
candidat
doit dire qu'on dira mme mandine dirhams
par mois on dira pas un mot le dit
parents et délices par de grands dangers
mais ça fait même pas un an que je suis
là divise par deux
cantons mercedes on va dire que j'ai pu
acheter la maison de ma maman voilà on
voit à peu près à peu près tout l'argent
tu l'as fait d'être mère c'est vrai j'ai
déjà un peu dans les simples mais sinon
j'ai touché la churchill a battu d'élus
hélas rien donné façon que c'est pas son
métier il gagne son argent par lui-même
tiens pas que l'arbre
toi
[Musique]
j'accueille kenza braga et olivia cattan
soir
[Musique]
alors qu'ils avaient été découverte par
le grand public lors de votre
participation à loft story depuis vous
êtes devenu journaliste à radio orient à
respect mag et à le mouv voilà vous avez
publié trois livres et vous est la
marraine de ni [__] ni soumises voilà
titre olivia vous êtes journaliste à
tribune juive vous collaborez également
à france soir et à paris match et toutes
les deux ensemble ou publié chez ram
c'est un livre qui s'appelle deux femmes
en colère avec une préface de marek
halter voilà alors c'est un coup de
gueule
contre les préjugés à l'encontre des
juifs et des musulmans mais aussi contre
vos propres communautés dont les
religions n'ont pas encore dit vous
intégrez les apports de la modernité
pour les femmes voilà alors que nous
avons raconté dans le bouquin une
anecdote qui explique vos motivations en
avril 2004 vous recevrez sur radio
orient vous travaillez dans une émission
qui se veut être 100% femme emilie
frèche pour un roman qui s'appelle le
sourire de l'ange où il est question de
l'amour impossible entre deux
adolescents un juif une musulmane et les
réactions des auditeurs vous choque d'où
l'idée de ce livre c'est vrai qu'à un
moment donné où l'ambiance s'est
transformée assez rapidement
on disons que la religion april pas sur
l'amour puisqu'en fait la thématique
essentielle de l'émission c'était
l'amour at il droit de cité et c'est
vrai qu'on se demandait justement si un
homme et une femme de confession
différente ou d'univers complètement
différent est ce qu'ils avaient la
possibilité de vivre leur amour au sein
d'un quartier sensible et est ce qu il
le vivait finalement de la même façon
que s'il était tout simplement au
centre-ville et c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
des réactions très très très agressive
d'abord vis-à-vis des mêlées frêche
divise évidement d'invités qui était sur
le plateau et vis-à-vis de moi aussi
parce que je suis très vite je suis très
vite passé pour les auditeurs qui
m'écoutait tous les jours enfin pas pour
tout le monde mais pourra en tout cas
quelques-uns de mes auditeurs pour un
peu la traître de service parce que j'ai
évoqué une thématique sur un amour
impossible entre une musulmane et un
juif et en fait je pense que j'ai
je pense qu'on a le droit dans ce pays
d'évoquer ce genre de sujet et
heureusement et je pense que c'est
possible et c'est vrai que le fait de
dire que c'est possible a choqué pas mal
d'éditeurs way de faire ce bouquin oui
c'est vrai que disons que on est passé
très très vite à une ambiance assez
assez lourde d'abord parce qu'on était
tous choqués par ce manque de tolérance
et puis ce manque de dialogue entre les
gens il ya eu des réactions vraiment
raciste on peut dire raciste et
antisémite à l'égard de mon invitée et
donc je vais défendu j'ai pris son g
prison son côté c'est normal c'était la
moindre des choses que je pouvais faire
et puis clairement je suis passé mois
pour la traître de service et elle
malheureusement pour les juifs de
service bien alors donc chez alain soral
qui vous a présenté l'une à l'autre
et donc vous commencé dans le bouquin
par parler de vos racines vous olivia
vous êtes juif pieds noirs d'algérie
d'alger en 1962 votre famille est venue
ans en métropole vous naissez en 67 et
vos parents sont très déçu de pas avoir
deux garçons surtout mon père qui
s'attendait à avoir un petit garçon donc
c'est vrai que ça soit chez les
musulmans chez les juifs la naissance
d'un petit garçon c'est beaucoup mieux
qu'une petite fille donc il y avait pas
de youyous de réjouissance à tous à tout
cette fête organisée pour pour la
circoncision et c'est donc c'est vrai
qu'à une petite déception mais ils se
sont habitués
alors l'école vous découvrez le racisme
en fait anti sémitisme vous fait traiter
de sale juif par départ des jeunes
filles catholiques à 6 ans asus mais moi
je peux pas dire que j'ai vécu vraiment
l'antisémitisme de la part des musulmans
moi ça a été vraiment bon c'était une
autre époque aussi j'ai quand même
trente huit ans maintenant donc c'était
vraiment
avec les catholiques avec l'extrême
droite aussi avec lesquels on se
bagarrait quand on sortait du pas ce qui
nous attendait devant donc c'était
c'était encore un autre anti sémitisme
circuit vous reprocher d'avoir tué jésus
quoi voilà la fédé ici on connaît
l'histoire alors 82 lors de l'attentât
de la rue marbeuf
duo terroriste carlos votre frère qui
était à l'école à côté de la rue marbeuf
est très choqué par sa les vitres sont
brisées il part dans la rue ils errent
dans les rues pendant quelques quelques
heures où ils ont laissé en fait ils ont
fait sortir dès qu'il ya eu l'explosion
et c'est donc c'est vrai que depuis ce
moment-là c'est sa vie a changé il est
devenu handicapé mais va garder des
séquelles oui des grosses séquelles de
grosses séquelles
et quand vous allez la sorbonne vous
vous battez quand on insulte israël moi
j'étais un peu la jules de service il
fallait que j'ai absolument un avis sur
israël donc partir du moment où vous
êtes juif il faut vous preniez fait et
cause pour une voie là pour soi pour
israël soit pour la cause palestinienne
mais il faut donner votre avis
impérativement donc c'est ça qui me moi
qui me choquait parce que je me sentais
française j'étais française avant tout
j'étais juif bien sûr c'est ma
confession et je suis très fier aussi
comme elle de mes origines mais pour moi
la française d'abord n'en déduis donc on
prenait toujours un parti et dis moi
qu'est ce que tu penses et ça c'est vrai
qu'il pour moi ça m'a ça m'a choqué ça
m'a marqué c'est ce que je me suis
sentie différente et vous aviez aussi
des problèmes avec les ashkénazes et
séfarades sont des arabes ben ouais on
nous appelle les juifs arabes on est on
est plus proche des arabes au niveau de
nos traditions de nos coutumes pour les
mariages pour 1 lune et pour plein de
choses
puisque avec les ashkénazes c'est vrai
voilà dos et vos racines à vous vous
étiez à bagdad
votre famille était très déçu d'avoir un
garçon aussi oui surtout surtout ma
grand mère ouais ouais tout à fait
d'ailleurs ma mère a pas être du tout eu
le droit aux youyous habituel justement
qu'on donne à un garçon et c'est vrai
que dès le départ
ma grand mère avait l'impression que le
ciel lui était tombé sur la tête quoi
ça leur éducation assez stricte mais
heureusement votre père bien terminer
ses études de médecine en france à nancy
à lyon donc là dessus une espèce de deux
bouffées d'air frais et au retour en
irak s'étaient élevées dans une grande
animosité contre les juifs oui c'est
vrai dans les manuels scolaires
il nous était régulièrement en tout cas
enseigner le fait que le sionisme était
justement s'entêter à détruire le monde
arabe ce que c'est vrai que pour saddam
tout le monde le sait l'unité arabe
était quand même l'un à l'un des
symboles de la réussite du monde arabe
en tout cas ils avaient envie de
construire justement l'unité d'élite et
arabes et c'est vrai que j'étais sous un
régime totalitaire et tout le monde sait
que sous un régime totalitaire la loi
est celle de celui qui vous gouvernent
ont clairement on n'avait pas le choix
c'était les juifs étaient des ennemis on
était des enfants réciter par coeur ce
qu'on nous donnait ce qu'on nous donnait
à lire et à apprendre et heureusement
qu'à 14 ans je suis sorti de ce pays ça
m'a vraiment de la première guerre du
golfe en 91 ou partez avec votre mère
vos frères vous arrivez en france oui
j'y arrive en france à 14 ans j'ai je
quitte en tout cas dans des
circonstances très particulières la
guerre en finlande l'irak avec ma mère
et mes deux petites soeurs et mais c'est
vrai que bizarrement on nous a appris à
détester le juif mais c'est vrai que
jamais dans ma famille dans laquelle
j'ai été élevé on ne m'a jamais dit en
tout cas à la maison qu'il fallait et
justement continuer à détester les juifs
lui qu'il fallait tuer les juifs etc
donc c'était vraiment dans les manuels
scolaires sets ça faisait partie de des
choses normales voilà du programme
scolaire tout à fait aujourd'hui qu'est
ce que vous pensez de ce qui se passe en
irak est ce que je pense de l'irak c'est
que je sais j'étais et je le suis
toujours à contre montre le le le fait
que les américains soient intervenues en
tout cas en irak je pense que les
irakiens auraient pu à un moment donné
et décider de leur propre sort et de
leur propre destin et c'est vrai que je
trouve que aujourd'hui les américains
s'enlise et malheureusement ils sont en
train de je crois que la situation se
retourne contre eux oui oui et je pense
clairement qu'on est très très proche
d'une guerre civile je crois que ça va
être très très compliqué ça c'est
formidable j'ai fait un livre les deux
oui à porter c'est vrai et puis c'est
vrai que c'est ça a été vraiment une
bouffée une bouffée d'oxygène ce livre
d'abord parce que j'ai appris beaucoup
de choses sur la religion juive et elle
est là aussi après bourdieu sur la
religion musulmane et puis on est des
femmes je sais pas je trouve qu'on a un
regard différent sur la religion sur les
rapports avec les gens on est on est
peut-être plus sensibles moi que moi je
trouve qu'il ya dans votre livre quelque
chose qui est éblouissant c'est le fait
que vous vous arrachez chacune à vos
communautés d'origine après des
trajectoires ou normalement vous devriez
vous détestez vous avez été programmé
pour vous détestez et au fond vous
montrer cette extraordinaire liberté que
vous avez par rapport à une tradition
qui vous programmez vous détestez de
vous aimer et ça je pense que c'est un
enseignement une leçon qui est mille
fois plus importante que si ça venait de
l'extérieur et qu'on disait aimez vous
les uns les autres que la république
intervenait pour dire mais vendée il
faut pas que les médecins de l'éducation
des parents mes parents m'ont toujours
élevés dans le respect d'abord mon mes
parents ont vécu avec avec les musulmans
donc c'est vrai qu'il disait côte à côte
en algérie donc il ya un moment dans
votre livre vous dites ça si votre père
qui vous dit attends nous allons vous
donner une gifle dit mais nous on est
qui habillés comme des arabes l'arabe
c'est ma première langue il ya aucune
raison de se détester qui mon père parle
parle arabe ma mère boit un petit peu
moins parce qu'elle est parti très tôt
mais c'est vrai que toute ma famille moi
j'ai été élevé avec des berceuses bercé
avec des berceuses arabe que chante
maintenant à mon vraiment le petit
garçon est petit maintenant mais il ya
encore des millions de personnes qui
vivent dans la tolérance et le respect
c'est pas un épiphénomène non et on
n'est pas obligé de se détester quand il
y avait pour moi n'y avait même pas de
haines communautaires entre nos
communautés ici pour moi il ya des
minorités bien sûr qu'à des minorités
bien sûr il ya des clichés antisémites
et l'actualité montre que
malheureusement on n'est pas sortis mais
pour moi c'est une minorité parce que
l'on vit très bien toutes les deux elles
à elle a suivi toute ma grossesse j'ai
accouché d'un petit garçon elle était
près de moi là oui les des ours ont
profité pour dire que donc demain à 15
heures place de la république
il ya une marche pour ilan halimi donc
voilà tout le monde peut y aller
évidemment
j'aimerais que tout le monde y aille sur
mgm inquiet tout le monde s'assoit pas
une affaire de juifs parce que la mort
de dylan il était quand même français
moi ce qui m'a choqué c'est qu'on a
présenté la faire au début on a dit la
communauté juive va être choqués va être
laissé va être en deuil il faut qu'elle
se calme etc mais pour moi c'est une
affaire de la république c'est une
affaire de tout le monde toutes les
mamans musulmanes doivent ressentir ce
que ruth halimi refonte ils en ont dans
leur chair ils doivent décembre et
j'espère qu'ils descendront moi je
trouve ce crime ignoble
et c'est vrai que j'ai été très très
choquée dans les circonstances dans
lesquelles en tout cas ilan est décédé
je voudrais juste dire une chose parce
que c'est vrai qu' on est tous plus ou
moins réactif selon nos origines et
selon si nos appartenances religieuses
je voulais juste lancé un appel pour que
finalement les esprits s'apaisent parce
que je crois que c'est très important je
crois qu'on est tous emportés par ce
tourbillon médiatique autour de cette
affaire c'est horrible on tue à dire on
est tous il faut tous en tout cas il
faut qu'on soit tous solidaires pour
dénoncer jeu ce genre de crime et que
cela ne se reproduise plus mais c'est
très très important si que ça ne soit
pas eu aussi une porte ouverte à de à
des amalgames et qu'on ne met pas tout
le monde dans le même panier voilà parce
que je pense que la majorité des
musulmans en france sont choqués par ce
crime et moi je pousse et je fais et je
lance un appel justement à tous les
musulmans de france à tous les français
de confession musulmane parce que c'est
très important les français on est
musulman il faut descendre et soutenir
la famille demain en tout cas à partir
de 15 heures c'est un appel au président
chirac
bien d'autres choses moi c'est le même
point de vue aussi c'est vrai que c'est
un problème qui est moi pour moi je
pense que ça regarde tout le monde c'est
pas simplement la communauté juive ou
vrai qu'on est tous concernés c'est moi
c'est un jeune qui a à peu près mon âge
et je
compatis tous à 12 je pense que même
même ma mère j'en parlais cet après midi
à avec ma mère me disait que kaka
participerait à ces manifestations quand
c'est dans le quartier le silence il ya
donc beaucoup de lâcheté et je trouve
que les gens ont peur et parce qu'ils
ont peur ils ne disent pas les choses et
je crois que nous sommes responsables de
la société si vous avez raison de dire
c'est pas une affaire us juive ou
palestiniennes ou arabes c'était un
française mais en même temps les gens
comment on peut savoir qu'un jeune homme
est enfermé pendant trois semaines dans
une cave est que personne ne sache rien
personne l'agent marc druz parisien donc
il ya une façon de 2,2 silencieuse qui
est une lâcheté et qu'il faut dire où je
ne pas avoir peur et que et que ce que
disait ma fille tout à leur faut pas non
plus dramatiser il ya beaucoup de gens
formidables bien sûr mais surtout qu'un
appel anonyme on aurait pu le sauver
quoi c'est ça qui est inquiet ça qui
arrive bien trop d'attentisme aussi de
la part des citoyens il faut peut-être
aussi con qu'on travaille là-dessus il
ya une phrase terrible de tristan
bernard qui disaient ils croient qu'ils
sont heureux parce qu'ils sont immobiles
ou jamais être immobile
or chez nous alors dans votre livre
après vos racines et vos histoires
personnelles vous raconter les mimiques
les clichés les fantasmes et les
préjugés auxquels vous avez été
confronté alors c'est vrai qu'à des
images comme ça qui rôdent quoi la râpe
musulmans membres s'étaient de celui qui
venait voler le pain des français voilà
c'était l'image et big o
ces voix-là effectivement et
malheureusement disons que les parents
en tout cas les les la génération de
leurs parents puisque il y a quelques
années étaient des [__] justement au
service de la france au service de
l'économie de la france et puis les
années après leurs enfants sont devenus
des racailles qu'on doit nettoyer au
kärcher donc je trouve ça quand même
lamentable qu'on passe quand même d'une
heure d'une image et l'amalgamé qu'on a
souvent dénoncé ici avec jamel debbouze
logicien le lendemain du 11 septembre
entre
musulmans intégristes qui est absolument
insupportable bien sûr que c'est un
supporter appui faut le dire quoi de
file le long 11 le 11 septembre les
musulmans à papa la cote quoi il n'a pas
la cote et c'est vrai que c'est terrible
quand même que les musulmans soient
devenus aussi dans la majorité des boucs
émissaires à bon compte toi
et moi je suis la première choqué parce
que je pense que la majorité des
musulmans en france dénonce ce genre de
terrorisme en tout cas on est tous les
musulmans en france sont contre les
terroristes contre les kamikazes et je
veux dire arrêtez la majorité des
musulmans dans la rue vous répondront la
même chose devrait rappeler quand des
journalistes français ont été enlevés en
irak ce sont les musulmans de france qui
se sont levés pour aller les défendre et
pour aller là-bas discuter avec les
autorités donc on a vu à l'époque
souvenez vous tous les observateurs
français est un peu un peu
étonné design et comment on pensait que
c'était une communauté fermée pas du
tout est en fait il était solidaire de
la france d'abord et avant tout de leurs
concitoyens d'abord et avant tout et
donc on a vu qu'ils se lever en revanche
c'est vrai que pardon de vous le dire
mais avec les la fir des caricatures de
mahomet vous n'y pouvez rien ça donne
une image
terrifiante de l'islam et il faut
beaucoup d'intelligence pour ne pas
faire l'amalgamme et donc moi je dis que
c'est pour ça que c'est très important
que ce soit des gens qui émane de la
communauté elle-même ou des communautés
elles mêmes qui disent non arrêtons et
je pense que sur un sujet comme celui
dont on parlait tout à l'heure cette
affaire allait milk est terrifiante il
faut aussi qu'on entende vraiment la
voix des musulmans qu'on entende ça se
voit là et c'est pour ça que j'y reviens
le fait que votre livre soit écrit à
deux voies comme ça c'est très important
quand on a vu alors on a vu les clichés
évidemment qui sont ravalés sur les
musulmans sur les juifs c'est pareil on
l'a vu encore avec la sphère de ilan
halimi les juifs sont riches dirigent le
monde
même quarante mille en france peut-être
le dire ça fait quand même 10 % la
communauté juive et il ya des déshérités
il ya valent
alors olivia vous évoqué l'agression
dans votre frère a été victime et le
refus du commissariat de considérer que
c'était une agression antisémite à cause
des quotas en fait c'est à dire que
c'est des directives dites vous qu ils
ont reçu six de pouvoir plus tard c'est
à dire que c'est une banlieue calme
paisible où il ya de bonnes statistiques
donc ya pas d'antisémitisme et y en aura
pas voilà donc ça faisait tache mon
frère s'est fait agresser ça fait tâche
ouais donc on n'a pas non à vous dire
que c'est voilà une agression antisémite
qui fait qu'après quand y publier des
statistiques
c'est évidemment les chiffres sont
meilleurs et vous évoquez dieu devez
vous dites la justice ne lui a jamais
donné tort à une époque où j'entendais
beaucoup de choses sur dieudonné donc je
me suis dit il faut quand même que
j'aille voir le spectacle parce que bon
j'aime pas les préjugés j'essaye de pas
en avoir et je suis pour la liberté
d'expression donc c'est vrai que je
voulais voir avant de condamner est ce
que j'ai vu ça m'a tellement c'est vrai
que ça m'a beaucoup choqué parce que je
trouvais que c'était une telle
incitation à la haine je me suis senti
vraiment très mal et je me suis dit bon
c'est vrai que là les clichés sont alors
là on passe de du peuple élu aux
sionistes
voilà ça ça dure deux heures et demi
d'acharnement sur les juifs et à notre
époque je trouve que c'est pas c'est pas
la bonne solution car elle va vous
raconter qu'ils allaient la
discrimination dont sont victimes les
musulmans dans la recherche d'emplois
dans la recherche de logement et surtout
qu'ils sont obligés de changer de prénom
pour trouver du boulot c'est terrible
quand même qu'on puisse renier ses
origines pourquoi retrouver un travail
quoi enfin moi je n'ai pas vécu
personnellement mais j'ai vécu par
contre la discrimination
pour trouver un appartement malgré
malgré le fait que il paraît que je suis
une comme on dit j'aime pas ce mot là
mais il paraît que je suis une arabe
lice à moi j'aime pas cette phrase là ça
veut dire quoi une arabie ça veut dire
qu'il ya des arabes qui sont lisses et
des arabes qui sont frisés et pas et pas
acceptable ça me semble et c'est vrai
que ma mère elle fait de superbes robes
je suis sûr
j'avais des frises
s'intégrer aussi et de prendre des noms
français simple non mais c'est vrai oui
mais on dirait que renier ses origines à
la fois c'est d'accepter le pays dans
lequel on
non mon père était rude le cerf en
tragédie crise' surtout en pleine crise
mais à des capitaux et il se trouve que
je m'appelle françois mon père fut dit
voilà on apprenne ont bien français
voilà on est bien français et puis y'a
pas
la famille est une famille des enfants
qui naissent pourquoi tout à coup garder
vraiment d'accord quoi alors pourquoi ne
pas dire que dieu n'existe pas tout
simplement comme ça il ya plus de soucis
comprenez-vous les musulmans
vous ça qui va bientôt s'appeler tout ce
qui est beau en france pour moi c'est je
passais la différence marche pouvoir
marcher doaré voir humble avec un beurre
et un blanc un juif c'est pas pour moi
c'est ça maintenant s'il faut passer par
là s'appelait mûri sous michel pour pour
pouvoir passer bien quelque part c'est
fou ça triste
pour moi c'est
des mois mais dd mamadou des noms mais
ça non mais quand je disais ça saigne à
m'emmener au fond quand même accepter
aussi la halle le pays dans lequel on
vit et puis à s'intégrer
je suis
là où vous rejoignez toutes les deux
c'est sur la condition de la femme parce
qu'on se rend compte en fait en lisant
votre bouquin que finalement les femmes
juives sont pas mieux lotis que les
femmes musulmanes alors les musulmanes
vous dites en tous les cas que d'après
la loi d'après le coran elles ont le
droit de choisir leur mari de divorcer
d'avoir leurs propres revenus c'est des
choses qui sont pas qu'ils sont pas
admises ça plutôt pas très connu dans
tous les cas c'est parce qu'on préfère
on préfère mettre en avant des versets
du coran qui sont beaucoup plus comme on
veut dire qu'ils sont
beaucoup plus négative pour la femme
parce qu'il ya des choses aussi qui sont
très belle dans la religion musulmane
moi il ya déjà des principes d'humanité
qui émane directement de du coran mais
bien sûr il faut aussi repositionné le
coran dans son époque clairement il ya
des versets du coran qui sont
inacceptables aujourd'hui vis-à-vis des
femmes forcément donc sur la virginité
sur les mariages forcés par exemple ou
témoin de mariage forcé je suis contre
et je trouve ça je trouve que c'est un
scandale je pense que il faut quand même
pas oublier que les chiffres sont assez
élevées au niveau du nez des mariages
forcés en france je ne saurais pas dire
combien mais à peu près et ça ces
approches des cinquante mille cas ici
encore en france des jeunes filles en
plus qui sont nés en france sauf qu'à un
moment donné il ya une fracture
culturelle qui fait que les parents
préfèrent marier leur fille au bled et
les envoyer se marier avec un homme de
la ba oui les pères ou les frères touré
effectivement voilà donc à une fracture
culturelle ans au sein de la famille qui
fait qu'à un moment il ya je sais pas y
ait un retour aux sources alors
concernant les femmes juives on va pas
épiloguer sur les obligations liées aux
monstres ulation j'ai découvert c'est la
beauté je savais pas du même temps ça ne
concerne qu'une minorité il faut bien le
dire aussi croire voilà c'est quand même
mon nom n'est pas comme ça on est pas
tous comme ça et voilà cette fois mais
en fait quand on appelle ça nida quand
on a ses règles on n'a pas le droit de
dormir avec son mari pendant son dort
sur un matelas séparer on reste pendant
7 jours après la laisse tremper dans un
dans un bain et après voilà et après on
a droit à l'arrêt comme un cri on a le
droit d' olivier gallot remonte sur lui
ouais tout à fait sympa je viens elle
divorce et c'est un truc que je savais
pas du tout enfin évidemment c'est des
gens qui sont très pratiquants très
orthodoxe j'imagine un pour le divorce
ah bon parce que ça me concerne aussi
par exemple ouais c'est le divorce la
femme doit obtenir l'accord de son mari
pour divorcer n'a pas besoin d'obtenir
l'accord de sa femme pour divorcer
c'est à dire que marie quand on se marie
si vous voulez moi quand je me suis
marié on signe tout les deux normalement
pour moi l'acte de mariage et quand
j'allais prendre le crayon pour signer
aux médias non toi tu signes passé
seulement l'homme qui signent et moi
j'ai trouvé ça
sinon si la boxe à la synagogue oui bien
sûr on peut divorcer civilement mais pas
religieusement donc après si on se remet
et seront se marient civilement avec
quelqu'un on est considéré comme
l'adultère donc les enfants de cette
union sont des bâtards donc c'est quand
même il est peut-être temps que ça
change il travaillait religieux moi
aussi oui et le mouvement libéral quand
même à changer les choses ils donnent
égalitaire etc mais il est peut-être
temps qu'en france parce qu'en france on
a quand même la palme du judaïsme
vieillot parce que après israël c'est
pas comme ça ouais donc c'est quand même
un peu étrange il est pas mal votre book
merci
cannes dont deux femmes encore
[Musique]
ja
mais juste laissé filer tous les deux
ensemble j'espère que marie caroline ne
prendra pas mal non je voudrais bien
marri cologna comme elle est très
gentille au revoir jean claude on va
j'accueille olivia bonamy et patrick
mille
à
savard est ici tous les deux pour un
film de jean-michel werner s'appelle
célibataire avec guillaume depardieu
serge hazanavicius cartouches et vous
deux c'est l'histoire de cinq
célibataires alors au début guillaume
depardieu demande sa fiancée en mariage
et c'est là qu'elle lui annonce qu'elle
le quitte il en avale sa bague de
fiançailles qui restera dans son ventre
pendant tout le film voit là et il va
voir un psy qui est beaucoup plus dingue
que lui d'ailleurs et il se réfugie chez
ses potes donc ses potes célibataire
alors olivia vous faisait pas une mecque
depuis depuis un an
cinéma el gargati les intérêts que vous
avez ça m'étonnerait ce que vous n'ayez
pas eu de mec depuis ah non mais bon
c'est dans le film olivia oui et vous
patrick est un paumé magnifique
cartouche qui est un photographe
vaguement homo serge hazanavicius qui
est un dentiste marié mai au bord du
divorce enfin bref une bande de
célibataires qui essayait de se
persuader que c'est sympa tout en
cherchant l'âme soeur mais en refusant
de s'engager quoi là c'est quand même
assez luxe voilà c'est très paradoxal
tout ça voilà arrivés terre génération
down ouais c'est vrai nom c'est vrai bah
oui il y en a rien à un sur trois quand
même ma mère est célibataire et par
rapport aux cinq ans et ils sont donne
les toiles et c'est vrai ils sont pas
très enviable ces célibataires
vous par exemple le personnage manque
terriblement d'ambition
professionnels oui professionnelle et
amoureuse aussi parce qu'elle cherche un
mec pour avoir une petite vie tranquille
quoi on le cherche vraiment à ouais
surtout
le chargement et son horloge biologique
qui la travaillent dans quel blindage
enfants alors elle croit que la
ménopause c'est à 35 ans oui donc elle
veut absolument faire un enfant très
rapidement évidemment il inquiète de lui
rendre le service mais c'est si c'est
assez triste c'est vrai finalement dans
papa le gisement qui est des bons
copains ouais et vous c'est pareil vous
êtes une espèce de branques avec
beaucoup de charme la nuit vous êtes
formidables traces de lait et plein
d'idées mais mais voilà vous voulez le
matin c'est plus dur bah oui quand il
grille vous n'arrivez pas à passer à
l'acte oui et puis c'est pas ici je
crois qu'il se rappelle même plus du nom
de la fille qu'il aime quoi il veut ils
vont il faut il veut faire des petites
entreprises il a plein de projets mais
que la nuit ouais prêt le matin c'est
fini il a plu c'est un peu pathétique
quand même un ouais c'est complètement
pathétique huawei mais cécilia des
personnages comme ça il ya des j'ai un
problème de micro ben c'est pour nous
toucher
non c'est vrai c'est ses impôts mais un
peu magnifique donc entre entre huit
heures du soir et 7h du matin et après
c'est plus à mon avis
c'est amer nom samuel ça va ça va ouais
j'ai la transférant ce moment toi ça va
d'un coutelas ya patrick mille olivia
bonamy
françois berléand olivia cattan et kenza
brigade laurent baffie ça ne surprendra
pas et amel bent tu connais mail bent
les y passe des coups de fil à discuter
cette chanson quand même
ah ouais
c'est un jeu qui s'appelle moussa pas
fini encore on était persuadés qu'ils
étaient
vraiment oui bien sûr je suis allé je te
dis à samedi s'est passée dans les airs
il a toujours son plus de merde
la vie aussi bien aussi oui d'abord ce
qu'on va faire on va regarder à quoi ça
ressemble tous les deux sens regardez
vos caméras laquelle rouge le cameroun
est à est à 3 vous dites manitoba
magnéto serge ya
faut dire que j'ai un gros avantage je
suis canaux le célibat c'était pas mon
truc mais sa gelée vraiment compris le
jour je veux nous faire vieillir
ensemble
c'est dur à avaler
benjamin as tu prends mais tu me quittes
rapport soit une merde statistiquement
un tiers de la population des
trentenaires ou deviendra ce mandataire
c'est mes sincères dans le sac poubelle
trois hommes ma vie dans un sac poubelle
faut les trouver nana comment on pouvait
il fallut trouver quelqu'un dans votre
vie c'est un désert total on est qu'est
ce que tu racontes moi c'est uniquement
parce que je veux être avec personne un
choix c'est tout laisse moi t'aimer
tout laisse tomber maintenant on voit
bien qu'elle veut pas te parler voici
comme tu me l'a demandé dans ton
précédent mais j'ai mis du temps à te
l'envoyer cas je suis un peu complexés
par moment donné
elle est pas belle la vie des potes
tartines de foie gras du saucisson d'âne
et aucune greluche qu'ils rendent des
comptes
c'est dingue je pensais justement la
tour à tout ça prend un ou dotés
l'avantagé quand tu es célibataire c'est
que quand tu rencontres une jolie femme
tu regrettes pas dans le bras une mouche
à la maison j'ai pas bien compris je
laisse tomber
sa soeur je vous prendre en photo c'est
un hommage à la poitrine de la femme
dans la rue tu veux que je te demande
mais ça c'est ça exactement ça
mesdames vous avez sept minutes pour
séduire mais pourquoi j'ai trouvé un mec
bien je te demande pas grand chose un
peu de tendresse alors les mecs
[Musique]
avec en gros
ce soir alors
comédie tard vous allez nous expliquer
on va commencer par vous pourquoi est-ce
qu'on devrait aller voir ce film moi je
vous dis oui la couverture de l'express
célibataire ouais il ce jeudi millions
d'il y ont dit nous si on a 10 millions
de téléspectateurs à la haine raciale
s'est pas décomposé cebu 17 buts les
messines milandes choristes un vrai il
ya eu huit millions et demi de
spectateurs comme quoi via 10 millions
de célibataires il peut y avoir qu'un
lien pour eux perdu millions être encore
olivier avait quelque chose à ajouter un
temps des coupes aussi peuvent y aller
parce que ça ça rassure oui mais ça
prend plus de monde aussi et même les
bronzés aussi peu violets ont récupéré
tout le monde non mais c'est vrai et le
fait aussi d'être seul d'y aller et de
rencontrer quelqu'un dans la salle ar je
crois que ça ça m'arrive c'est un moment
et ça ça va arriver forcément des gens
vont se regarder vos mpeg la non mais là
tu arrives à faire là sekkaki ça c'est
une affaire qui tombe ça j'ai vu
contrairement à ce qu'on sait il pas de
bagnole alethia tout ça
ah ouais mais on va se voir après
l'affiché bien d'oussama c'est bon ça
sent bon la
répéter
on passe au blind test
jouer les jokers bons amis
soit
la barre de plein été
donc vous serez tous les soirs sur la
scène du théâtre de 10 heures à 20
heures à partir du 14 mars dans les
aventures de bob et rémy les deux flics
les plus drôles de la télé il paraît y
paraît alors vous allez dire magnéto
serge on va regarder à vos caméras elle
est où là c'est bien ouais c'est noir
c'est le cas le rouge madame rouge après
3 4 magnéto serge
laisse moi je te dis je te dis que c'est
pas le moment juste une toute petite
démo vernis facile à personne d'accord
mais sûrement la démo bonjour monsieur
voilà mon vieux fallait pas vous notre
premier rang
mais alain vous êtes de droite c'est pas
une question taboue
pas la peine d'aller casser
je bloque l'individu
je redouble individus
je pense à l'exécution des jeux mac os
l'âne et du cheval à la longe de déchets
l'individu personne ne bouge
le coupable est dans la place on vient
chercher
sakho
caffery ont fait peur mais terreur paix
qui passent jamais
m
à paris
[Musique]
m
l'a75 mais les 75
le foot
on sait que guitariste
les récents matches
détends toi massif et
canal
à ça comment regarder chanter du monde
et pour m j'avais mal au dos santos
en haut de cet article au paris paris
nous écoutera est-ce que l'on tombera
sur le générique de fin à ces notes and
the guest list
exactement j'étais prêt tiens on y va
quand google
défie les règles du jeu est simple c'est
l'équipe de françois berléand contre
l'équipe de laurent baffie je veux
l'interprète a
annoncé vas-y
manureva manuel santos
[Musique]
philosophe que des philosophes ce soir
et pourtant non attends eh bien tu
arrêtes il a dit interprète la dérive
est laurent baffie on demand ou rêva oui
tu dis chamfort bien après ce premier
quart et
moi vous les gens zappent et
d'autres plus
sur scène et césar maintenant c'est bien
on continue
je
[Musique]
ah ah
ap deux points pour les cueilleurs on a
pris en compte
six à la cop16 serait prodigieux c'est
comme mon réveil j'ai pas qui à l'âge
enfant on a trouvé avant oui mais vous
avez pas deschamps forbes et du manureva
basé sa quête d'un pantois risque
important c'est l'interface hockey
est-ce que je suis interprète un peu toi
dans l'opéra un truc un peu difficile
arrive ça arrive tu vas voir ta chanson
française je vais aller avec eux la
presse que la raison pure forme revient
à la route
[Musique]
à
m j'y vais ça fait trois fois certains
concepts quoi
at il dit après le temps non attends
quoi patrick un tout petit peu ouais bon
replay serge voilà
ça venait pas d'eux
[Musique]
alors non non c'est pas ma carte l'un
qui chante ses droits c'est pas les
seuls c'est pas le macabre mais qui
change j'ai gagné
[Musique]
on dit et le répète madonna non
non
[Musique]
non c'est rémy dès ses premiers noms
annoncés les 1000 premiers sur les mines
on voit l'affairé mills et nous c nous
marée noire c'est vrai je veux pas tendu
avec la police
[Applaudissements]
enfant j'ai
choisi
[Musique]
on avait dit pas les jours
c'est pas de problème n'est pas
d'avoir un poids pour toi et quelquefois
pour eux
mêmes sans madonna j'ai une grande
histoire du temps on continue pas de
pain
qu'est ce qui pourrait vous donner dans
les boîtes
voilà voilà
mais ça tape à l'autoradio
des forces de la rhonelle et plus vos
dîners normaux comme un enquête de kay
qu'il soit 4 charisma paiement c'est
bien c'est bien marco
freddie mercury lady gaga queen
belga
et
à
vous
ouais
ça me fait marrer devant des flics qui
sont sur le marché
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'appel de m
non
et
m
ça a fait clic de george michael je
veux dire c'est ouais je n'ai connu ya
vingt ans une trentaine pdl
et est ce que je t'ai rien n'existe pas
leur entérine la plus con ephésiens
musée vous et laurent mine dorée soit
4,4 ça sent bien
à temps mais c'est bon on répond à tous
et 9,4 4,4 attendu petit pull marine
attention gauthier guy marcot
on a gagné
wes comme les deux doigts
évident c'est bien
toi qui insuffle la gagne
en anglais je n'ai jamais battu allant
de lèse majesté
voilà tu vois
vraiment des siliques 20 ans de radio
tous les gens qui chantent dans
l'axé fort
[Applaudissements]
non
nous disons non
[Musique]
et
là
faire
sans kaka mme chocat cannes
voilà un
replay
tu es
m
à temps
oui disent non non
[Musique]
voilà
kamchatka des noms
hamel
excuse moi c'est moi
donc rebecca ça nous fait quoi ça j'ai
pas la connerie à l'issue du bar équipe
sache s'il vous plaît toujours vous êtes
derrière nous
m
gueule tâche et on paie
ses impôts sublime à ses vrais parents
ont passé maintenant ah non c'est déjà
un petit pour départager les deux
équipes sony à la sueur attends attends
attends kenani
début des années 80 ah merde raison que
je peux répondre ai dit attention il est
prêt à monter jusqu'à 1 to français
c'est pas français je faisais moi tu
veux un truc français toutefois les
dangers de 700 ch et zach moss
[Applaudissements]
le monde
sportive la maison à bekasi les
connexions
soit beau joueur hors norme et à notre
attention attention
personne
[Applaudissements]
on remet en jeu encore une fois
attention attention balle de match à
tous qu'un peu moins cons que maintenant
quand je pensais pas faire
un truc plus pu empêcher un truc pour
toi mais non mais non on va trouver des
mélodies tirées sans pas récent mais tu
vois qu'on ait lieu attention vous êtes
prêt on se concentre
ça compte pas attention
[Musique]
derrière ma vie n'a rien à dire il
revient
donc aux par équipes c'est l'équipe de
françois berléand qui gagne hexagonal
[Applaudissements]
à
c'est alors j'attends les personnes
permanentes
maintenant on passe au chacun pour sa
gueule d'ailleurs plus dépité car c'est
la fin du par équipes la tient sous la
halle la paire d'yeux un truc et
pagesjaunes d'ailleurs si le mini banco
marco
[Musique]
c'est
donc la jouer à domicile 1 à 8 juin 2010
a donc été bon on est vraiment et banc
arrageois j'ai beaucoup fait remarquer
musulmane la mesure doit bien sûr on
continue marco
bührer
[Musique]
non
m
bien
attention le super banco ah oui c'est
quoi sur marco la danse est un angolais
souple pas
[Musique]
m
annoncée la syrie je tiens émissions non
non
j'ai connaissent ils vraiment
c'est justin roberts a fait chou blanc
quelle est ta femme d'accord j'ai baisé
nos fans mais beaucoup attention jeu en
ce qu'on semble
[Musique]
soit
ce final comme d'hab rang des juges
jacques chirac élu là dessus
la belle chanson chaban delmas pour
notre
nom avons avancé vous plaît les manceaux
il est au boulot mais vous pouvez aller
au boulot mais je sais ça pour toi tu
sais que pour lui attention on m'appelle
l'innocent du village
c'est joli ça venait elle est
la ville dans change qui sait gourville
non jean claude brialy ou alors un
fernandel tu vois je sais bien un truc
c'était pas loin je n'ai pas loin et ali
on passe à l'ultra bon
la ville
ici
du fric
[Musique]
m
titanic
[Musique]
tu sais qui
salut
[Musique]
samedi
tu passes ça au pari paraît y est
interdite dès 6h et 6h30 du matin par
terre en train de rentrer il écoute
savent même pas ce que c'est voilà et
donc on va en tant que générique de fin
note
laurent c'était tout le monde en parle
oui les plus belles émissions qu'il
m'ait été donné de voir thierry france
que j'ai hâte de rentrer à la maison
pour la repasser
c'était du vent n'a pas avec leur
fiche de contourner vite c'est tout
photo étienne giguère sorti le poleman
catherine ruelle françois berléand
dernière
image c'est pourquoi le coach à croix
blanche aurait dépensé plus que les
auteurs
mais cherche ni à mes fans l'album
s'appelle un jour d'été le single je
retiens pas tes la contourner le 26 mars
[Musique]
kenza braille 14,9 en colère
célibataire de journée solidaire avec
olivia bonamy vente aux enchères de
photos de mode exposées au bon marché
jusqu'au 6 mars au profit d'associations
caritatives
c'est des photos que tu as fais toi il
ya en fait il ya 9 me à huit femmes
qu'ont compris des photos lors de
défilés j'en ai pris quelques années et
les sous seront versés à des
associations
en fait est la mienne ce sera là dit une
association qui aide les chômeurs à
créer leur entreprise c'est important
merci
marco dos santos il ya longtemps que ça
perturbe encore
il n'ya pas d'émission la semaine
prochaine avant à banon rendez-vous dans
rendez-vous dans quinze jours
ok
[Musique]
trop tout au plus
ok
[Musique]
m
à petit
[Musique]
il y en a m
ici
[Musique]
et
vous
la ch'ti
taux
[Musique]
et
ouf
oui
samedi
google
tarifs
ayew
[Musique]
tu peux
il
yala m
tu veux
[Musique]
guérini
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un peu
de bleu